are you prepared to have your mind expanded to learn things you may not have known and to go places that might be a little unexpected to talk with people who can teach you things to learn about culture music and art well you're not gonna get that here because this is smart list here we go wait two pieces of business right up front okay let's go business one Jason Bateman just recently won the Screen Actors Guild award we couldn't be happier this is gonna air months months yeah I get it but it just kind of happened recently and it was really exciting I little tear I got welled up I was so
你准备好拓展思维、学习你可能不知道的事情、去一些意想不到的地方、与能教你知识的人交谈，了解文化、音乐和艺术了吗？好吧，你在这里可得不到这些，因为这是《SmartLess》，我们开始吧。等等，先处理两件事，好的，开始吧。第一件事，杰森·贝特曼最近刚赢得了美国演员工会奖，我们再高兴不过了。这期节目要几个月后才播出，是的，我明白，但这事儿刚发生，真的很令人兴奋。我流了一点眼泪，我太
happy and so proud I'm just trying to chase you what do you got four of them now I got for who's keeping score who's keeping score yeah that's right shit it's so far yeah yeah well we're we're trying and I wish my hair looked as good as yours this morning you did you get up early would you have a call back or something by the way slept in our new merch shirt it's so comfortable oh that is the merch store is up isn't it yeah it's yeah here's what I say about our merch sleep in it don't sleep on it you know I mean oh my god are we paying you extra for marketing no all of this stuff and these are just the tops of headsies
高兴也太骄傲了。我只是在追赶你，你现在有四个了吧？我有四个，谁在记分啊？谁在记分？是的，没错，该死，目前为止是这样。是的，是的，我们在努力，我真希望我今天早上的头发能像你的一样好看。你是起得早吗？还是有什么回电之类的？顺便说一下，穿着我们的新周边T恤睡的，太舒服了。哦，周边商店上线了是吧？是的，关于我们的周边，我想说的是：穿着它睡觉，别错过它，你懂我意思吗？天哪，我们是不是多付你营销费了？不，所有这些东西，这些只是头顶上的装饰。
yeah I call them tops of headsies wait and then the other order business is Jay had an emergency root canal yesterday yeah why did did you not feel it coming on why did it was it was whenever I would crunch on something that didn't crunch you know like a like a like a popcorn pill that doesn't well put no pills if you really come down and like I need this it will collapse sure but you know a bacon bit oh yeah or bacon bits are you eating like that would send me into down to my knees well you eat so many nuts and by the way insert joke here but but and also nuts here but but you you do you do eat a lot of nuts I
是的，我管它们叫“头顶装饰”。等等，另一件事是杰森昨天做了紧急根管治疗。是的，你没感觉到它要发作了吗？为什么？每当我咬到什么东西，那种不会碎的东西，你知道，比如那种没爆开的爆米花粒，或者那种硬东西，如果真的咬下去，它就会崩掉。当然，但你知道，培根碎，哦是的，培根碎，你吃那种东西会让我跪倒在地。好吧，你吃太多坚果了，顺便说一句，这里可以插入笑话，但你确实吃很多坚果。
do and seeds and sometimes seeds don't don't collapse either on a heart so anyway it's hard for me to go down on nuts to the seed the seed is stored in the nuts right the seed is stored in the nuts yes yes I see I hear what you did so it was all of the sudden so yeah so I had a bad a bad bite on some overly fried rice a rice kernel that was fried up too hard in the pan so that took me down a Sunday and then I had to get in there Monday and so what they did was that was that pre-sag awards yeah was that it was it was I managed to fumble through my acceptance speech with a hurt tooth I got skills you know pain
还有种子，有时种子咬下去也不会碎。总之，我很难去吃坚果，种子是藏在坚果里的，对吧？种子是藏在坚果里的，是的，是的，我听出你的意思了。所以这事儿发生得很突然，我咬到了一些炸得过头的炒饭，一颗炸得太硬的米粒，周日就把我击倒了，周一我不得不去看医生。所以那是美国演员工会奖之前吗？是吗？我带着牙痛勉强完成了获奖感言，我有技巧，你知道，对疼痛
tolerance just kind of grit what was ever what was left of your teeth and got through it I did so you so in a sense you acted like everything was okay I was up there for acting excellence yes yes no one was the wiser Sean and so so then so then I sit in the doctors the dentist chair yesterday morning and and he he said yeah you're gonna need a root canal and I said when do we do that he goes well we can do it today if you want to and he just stared at me and I stared at him and he blanked and I blanked and he wondered if I had you know the stones to actually go for it and I was like let's do this and he's lean
的忍耐力，咬紧牙关，剩下的牙齿，就这么挺过来了。我做到了。所以，从某种意义上说，你表现得一切正常。我在台上展现了卓越的演技，是的，是的，没人察觉到，肖恩。所以，昨天早上我坐在牙医椅上，他说：“是的，你需要做根管治疗。”我说：“我们什么时候做？”他说：“如果你愿意，今天就可以做。”他盯着我，我也盯着他，他愣住了，我也愣住了，他想知道我是否有胆量真的去做。我说：“来吧。”他把
the chair back and you yeah no and when they started drilling and about 45 minutes into drilling right when I thought I was through the worst of it he then gives me a play-by-play says okay now I'm gonna slice out the root or no no he says now I'm gonna remove the nerve oh god you don't need to tell me well like I just pictured this you know large animated angry red worm that he's gonna slice through and pull out and I just it was just so dumb of him that's a lot of nerve yeah was it was it I think a lot of nerve really oh shandy are you getting a fax did a fax just come through Sean what happened listen we got
椅子放倒，然后当他们开始钻的时候，钻了大约45分钟，就在我以为最糟糕的时候过去了，他开始给我现场直播，说：“好了，现在我要切除牙根。”或者不，他说：“现在我要移除神经。”哦天哪，你不需要告诉我。我就想象着这（神经）是一个巨大的、愤怒的红色蠕虫，他要把它切断并拉出来，他这么说真是太蠢了。那确实需要很多神经（勇气），是吗？我想是的，真的需要很多神经。哦，肖恩，你在收传真吗？刚才是不是有传真过来了，肖恩？发生了什么？听着，我们
away at Sean's doing some reading is it okay should we pause it printed on my printer okay let's turn all the devices off everything's on silent do you think people are do you think people are just like butt printing you what's going with their butts sorry I butt printed you nothing that's an emergency comes through the fax anymore Sean no I got a phone call I got a phone call hang on a second guest will's not done well we can kind of said but I got a phone call from our friend Conan O'Brien yesterday I saw I missed it so I called him back I don't don't even speak his name to me and I texted him I guess it's about the
肖恩在看东西，没关系吗？我们要暂停吗？在我的打印机上打印出来的，好吧，把所有设备都关掉，全部静音。你觉得人们是在“屁股打印”吗？他们的屁股怎么了？抱歉，我屁股打印了你。没什么，现在还有什么紧急情况会通过传真发过来吗，肖恩？不，我接到了一个电话，我接到了一个电话，等一下。嘉宾威尔还没做完，我们可以说，但我接到了我们朋友柯南·奥布莱恩昨天的电话，我看到了，但我错过了，所以我回拨了。别跟我提他的名字，我给他发了短信，我想是关于
holidays next year because everybody he's working on the list already sending out the group photos from everybody you know this motherfucker I guarantee you our guest was at that party guarantee we're gonna we're gonna open with that so I said sorry I missed your colon he goes it was a butt doll even my ass hangs up on you it is a problem about having your your your name be be starting with an a yeah all the but all right I get all the but tiles from people all the time all the time anyway what's even more pathetic is that you called him back hey man you didn't leave a message you want me well we had been we had been texting
明年的假期，因为每个人都在忙着列名单，发送大家的合影，你知道这个混蛋。我敢保证我们的嘉宾就在那个派对上，我保证。我们要以此开场。所以我说：“抱歉，我错过了你的电话。”他说：“那是个屁股拨号。”连我的屁股都会挂断你的电话。名字以A开头确实是个问题，是的，我总是收到各种屁股拨号，总是这样。总之，更可悲的是你还回拨了。嘿伙计，你没留语音，你想要我……好吧，我们一直在发短信，
and then so I figured that he was like sick of texting so he just wanted to get to phone so it's like no I didn't didn't want a longer conversation and I've been kind of shitty I'd sent him because he'd been texting me this thing and I and he was like can I ask you to the bubble I go yeah man I go I'm a very busy person wait he was inviting you to something else yeah he's doing this but you know his Easter jamboree you couldn't even get that out you are talk so quick today Willie who says jamboree how do you have that word ready you know what I just noticed after how many years now will that when you laugh
然后我想他可能厌倦了发短信，所以他只是想打电话，所以并不是说我不想进行更长的谈话。我有点糟糕，我发给他，因为他一直在给我发这个东西，他说：“我能邀请你参加那个聚会吗？”我说：“是的，伙计，我很忙。”等等，他是在邀请你参加别的东西？是的，他在搞那个，你知道他的复活节狂欢派对。你甚至说不出来，威尔，你今天说话太快了。谁会说“狂欢派对”？你怎么会准备好这个词？你知道我刚才注意到了什么吗？威尔，多少年了，当你笑得
really hard you hold your left eye as if it's going to pop out it's just the left eye that's loose I think right you just hold right underneath the eye you're drifting I think that's my that's the one so it'll fall with a real big laugh gang this week's guest is one of my favorite people and talents here we go he is able to make you laugh or cry he can act or direct he also writes and produces ladies he's a Gemini an avid reader and allergic to peanuts sounds like I catch peanuts peanuts peanuts that better he's been a part of 50 movies and a lot of TV in fact there he's received three Emmy Awards three DGA
特别厉害的时候，你会捂住左眼，好像它要掉出来一样。我想只有左眼是松的，对吧？你只是捂住眼睛下面，你在漂移，我想那是我的，那是那只眼睛，所以大笑的时候它会掉下来。各位，这周的嘉宾是我最喜欢的人和天才之一，我们开始吧。他能让你笑或哭，他能演戏或导演，他还写作和制作。女士们，他是双子座，一个狂热的读者，对花生过敏。听起来像是我抓到了花生，花生，花生，那样更好。他参与了50部电影和很多电视节目，事实上，他获得了三项艾美奖，三项美国导演工会奖，
Awards three WGA Awards but the three daughters he has are his favorites guys he's a lover not a hater ladies and gentlemen it's Bill I think I bet you I've got to be the best at the intros can we just yeah when you were saying I was like oh it's very well as always improvising them I take time and I shape I shape that's what's the worst part I think that's the most damning thing is that you actually put time in that hi Bill hater how are you guys so Bill did you go to Conan's Christmas Party I did yeah I did were you invited the year before as well I was yeah yeah those are intense how many years has he
三项美国编剧工会奖，但他有三个女儿，那是他的最爱。伙计们，他是个爱人，不是个恨者，女士们先生们，是比尔·哈德。我想我敢打赌，我是介绍词写得最好的。我们可以……是的，当你说话的时候，我就想，哦，这总是即兴发挥的。我花时间去塑造，去塑造，这是最糟糕的部分，我想这是最令人沮丧的事情，就是你真的花时间在上面。嗨，比尔·哈德，你们好吗？所以比尔，你去柯南的圣诞派对了？我去了，是的，我去了。你前一年也被邀请了吗？我被邀请了，是的，是的，那些派对很激烈。他举办了多少年了？
been having that well I mean wait everyone has had that house oh you guys were that were you guys there when the couch caught on fire I've always been there yeah yeah when the couch he's inside and he's talking and you know when Conan's had a couple two glasses of wine because he's like when I was a rider and then behind him is couch caught on fire and it wasn't a bit and we're all like going Conan the house some fire and he went oh wow it was very sweet wasn't he was he head writer went by the time he left I know I love Bill haters on the phone and we're talking about Conan no but no I think Conan he
好吧，我是说，等等，每个人都去过那个房子。你们在沙发着火的时候也在场吗？我一直都在，是的，是的，当沙发……他在里面说话，你知道柯南喝了两杯酒，因为他会说“当我还是个编剧的时候……”，然后他身后的沙发着火了，这不是演戏，我们都喊：“柯南，房子着火了！”他去：“哦，哇。”这很可爱，不是吗？他是首席编剧吗？当他离开的时候，我知道，我喜欢比尔·哈德在电话里，我们在谈论柯南。不，不，我认为柯南他
had to be like one of the top writers on the show yeah I don't know if he was ever head writer but he certainly is I don't know I think I think I think Jim Downey was always the head writer when he was there Jim Downey man I couldn't book him Bill what's number one on my list here fascinating wiki page by the way have you read have you ever have you ever read your wiki page have you ever edited your wiki page no no well have you ever read your wiki page don't lie yeah I've read it before sure haven't you Sean I have not yeah Sean read it years ago I have no idea I think you can get in there and change it right didn't
一定是节目组的顶级编剧之一。是的，我不知道他是否当过首席编剧，但他肯定是……我不知道，我想吉姆·唐尼一直是他还在那儿时的首席编剧。吉姆·唐尼，天哪，我没法预约他。比尔，我名单上的第一件事是什么？顺便说一句，迷人的维基页面，你读过吗？你有没有读过你的维基页面？你有没有编辑过你的维基页面？没有，没有。好吧，你读过你的维基页面吗？别撒谎。是的，我读过，当然。你没读过吗，肖恩？我没有。是的，肖恩几年前读过。我不知道，我想你可以进去修改它，对吧？我们不是
we change the rose once yeah Kimmel used to change the rose right yeah we we yeah we wrote we wrote on the rose wiki page that he he's a he's a I don't think we called him a cum crier but we said that he does he does cry after he ejaculates right but it stayed there for a good day or two I think we told him about it on his birthday okay hey Bill yeah we're interested in comedy as a kid this is a German interview with you the class clown in Germany the clowns are very sad wait Bill you know what I can't help thinking I'm so sorry to bring
改过一次玫瑰吗？是的，坎摩尔过去常改玫瑰，对吧？是的，我们……我们在玫瑰的维基页面上写道，他是个……我不认为我们叫他“射后哭泣者”，但我们说他确实在射精后会哭，对吧？它在那里保留了一两天，我想我们在他生日那天告诉了他。好的，嘿比尔，我们对你小时候的喜剧很感兴趣，这是一篇关于你的德语采访，班级小丑，在德国，小丑都很悲伤。等等，比尔，你知道我忍不住在想，很抱歉提起
this up but every time I see you and we're all fans that is is the story of Megan Mullally seeing you and calling one Michael yeah and like saying hey you need to see this guy is that true I was in a I was at a class I was a like a class show at Second City LA and her yeah brother-in-law Matt Offerman and I were in the same show together and she saw me and it was like you know she's from Oklahoma I'm from Oklahoma so anytime you meet someone else from Oklahoma you're like you know there's a mural of them someplace you know it's always like oh my gosh you know and she was like you're really funny and that was
这件事，但每次我见到你，我们都是粉丝，那个梅根·穆拉利看到你并给洛恩·迈克尔斯打电话的故事是真的吗？我在洛杉矶第二城参加一个班级演出，她的姐夫马特·奥弗曼和我一起参加了同一个演出，她看到了我，就像你知道的，她是俄克拉荷马人，我也是俄克拉荷马人，所以每当你遇到另一个俄克拉荷马人，你就会觉得……你知道，某个地方有他们的壁画，总是像“哦天哪，你知道吗？”她当时说：“你真的很搞笑。”那是
and I didn't think so but had you auditioned for SNL before or no no no no I didn't have it and she was like you're really funny and I was like oh thanks and I was working as an assistant editor on Iron Chef America wow I know I couldn't get the main thing is a lot of like Bill get the lights you know right yeah yeah yeah assistant editor was like Bobby Flay electrocuted himself can you take that out you know yeah so now so Megan Mullally was that close to Lorne Michaels that she could actually pitch I guess so I think she had just hosted okay and so she called him up and then I got a call from I was in my edit bay and
我没这么想，但你之前试镜过《周六夜现场》吗？没有，没有，没有。她当时说：“你真的很搞笑。”我说：“哦，谢谢。”我当时在《铁人料理美国版》做助理剪辑师。哇，我知道，最主要的是很多像“比尔，把灯拿来”之类的，对吧？是的，是的，助理剪辑师就像是“波比·弗雷电到了自己，你能把它剪掉吗？”你知道，是的。所以梅根·穆拉利和洛恩·迈克尔斯关系那么近，她竟然能推荐？我想是的，我想她刚主持过。好的，所以她给他打了电话，然后我接到了一个电话，我当时在我的剪辑室里，
Lindsay shook us call me no way like I work I hey is Lindsay shook us and she was Mark you know Marcy Klein's like yeah she was brand whisperer yeah yeah and she said hey you know Lauren like to meet you blah blah and I was like Lauren Lauren would like you to come and wait in the hall outside his office at 1 a.m. and then meet him at 4 30 yeah met him at 4 no that's 100% what happened nothing makes me more nervous about the auditioning process than waiting to go in I went in I was just sitting there and then I sat in that outer office on the ninth floor for four hours and then someone came in like hey
琳赛·舒卡斯给我打电话，没可能吧，我工作……嘿，我是琳赛·舒卡斯，她是马西·克莱恩的……是的，她是品牌耳语者。是的，是的，她说：“嘿，你知道洛恩想见你，等等。”我说：“洛恩？洛恩想让你凌晨1点去他办公室外的走廊等，然后在4点半见他。”是的，4点见他，不，那百分之百发生了。没有什么比等待试镜的过程更让我紧张的了。我进去了，我只是坐在那儿，然后在九楼的那个外办公室坐了四个小时，然后有人进来：“嘿，
we're gonna go have dinner now and I was like with Lauren and it was like oh no no no just you and me and then that's like awkward small talk very nice people and then yeah I finally was at dinner with who is that dinner with I was just Lindsay and oh my gosh I forget the other person but it was one of his assistants and then this is like 2000 early 2005 and then I and then I finally go in to see him and he goes do you know why you're here and I said oh make him well he says she saw me he's like you know I was on a boat once with a guy and he was funny the way that Bill Murray is funny and I thought to myself I know
我们要去吃晚饭了。”我说：“和洛恩一起？”他说：“哦不不不，就你和我。”然后那是尴尬的闲聊，非常友好的人，然后是的，我终于和……那是和谁吃的晚饭？只是琳赛和……哦天哪，我忘了另一个人，但那是他的助手之一。然后这是2005年初，然后我终于进去见他，他说：“你知道你为什么在这儿吗？”我说：“哦，梅根·穆拉利。”他说她看到了我。他说：“你知道我曾经和一个人在船上，他很搞笑，就像比尔·默瑞那样搞笑，我心想，我认识
Bill Murray and then it was like do you want to hang out tomorrow and watch the show and I was like sure and he was like all right and you know who and then you know who hosted the next week when I did my show was you Jason me when you hosted the first time the first was I that was when it was Tuesday night riding night of when you hosted they made the cast some of the cast members and people come and watch me perform no way because I remember early 2005 that was like what like January February yes yeah how do you know that will that will because I have a fucking crazy and I was sitting there going to go yeah we're
比尔·默瑞。”然后他说：“你想明天过来看看节目吗？”我说：“当然。”他说：“好吧。”然后你知道谁……你知道下周谁主持了我的节目吗？是你，杰森。当你第一次主持的时候，那是周二晚上的写作之夜，当你主持的时候，他们让一些演员和人来看我表演。没可能，因为我记得2005年初，那是……像一月、二月？是的，你怎么知道的，威尔？因为我有一个该死的疯狂的……我当时坐在那儿想：“是的，我们
writing that Jason Bateman's hosting this week and you know we got to get back so hurry come on you got to like because he needs a lot of writing yeah I had a sketch group and my like sketch slash audition piece was in the middle of the show and Lindsay shook us around the back and was like just do that sketch come on but here's my question though it's like it Megan so Megan made this call to Lauren Lauren called you but did you have any aspirations to do that or were you just like sure I guess I'll show up because somebody called I always I came to LA to be a director those were always my heroes you know I was like
在写杰森·贝特曼这周主持的节目，你知道我们得赶快，所以快点，你得……因为他需要很多剧本。”是的，我有一个小品组，我的小品/试镜片段在节目中间，琳赛·舒卡斯在后台说：“就做那个小品，快点。”但这是我的问题，梅根打了这个电话给洛恩，洛恩给你打了电话，但你有任何抱负去做那个吗？还是你只是想：“好吧，我想我会出现，因为有人打了电话。”我来洛杉矶是为了当导演，那些一直是我心目中的英雄，你知道，我当时在
writing directing and then but I you know I mean back especially late 90s early 2000s it was still like had to be on film you know I mean video didn't look as good as now and I had no money so a way to be creative was a friend of mine said oh do you want to take classes with me at Second City and we'll just mess around and and it was really fun but it was always like so when I got on SNL I was so envious of the Lonely Island guys that they were making short films yeah yeah so I was like well can I go hang out while you guys are making those so I can because that's my world that's what those were the digital shorts for
写作、导演，但你知道，我的意思是，特别是在90年代末、2000年代初，还是必须在胶片上，你知道，我的意思是，视频看起来没有现在好，我没钱，所以一个有创意的方法是，我的一个朋友说：“哦，你想和我一起在第二城上课吗？我们只是随便玩玩。”这真的很有趣，但一直都是……所以当我进入《周六夜现场》时，我非常羡慕“孤独岛”那帮人，因为他们在拍短片。是的，是的，所以我当时想：“好吧，我能去看看你们拍那些吗？因为那是我的世界。”那些是为
Tracy yeah for Tracy I remember Bill I remember early on when you came on the show like early and we're at an after party with your folks it must have been one of your first shows do you remember that we were sitting outside my dad lost his mind over will my dad really there was huge there were huge are his parents were huge arrested fans remember that bill yeah my dad goes no fucking way well holy shit and he kind of had will up against the wall it was at that place that's right across the street from 30 rock on 6th Avenue exactly yeah yeah bill good and I was going dad dad dad dad relax and he was like no fucking way
特雷西拍的数字短片。是的，为了特雷西。我记得比尔，我记得你刚来节目的时候，很早，我们在一个庆功派对上和你父母在一起，那一定是你最早的几期节目之一，你记得吗？我们坐在外面，我爸爸对威尔失去了理智，我爸爸真的……那里有巨大的……他的父母是《发展受阻》的超级粉丝，记得吗，比尔？我爸爸说：“没门，威尔，天哪。”他把威尔逼到了墙角，就在30号洛克菲勒中心对面，第六大道上，没错。是的，是的，比尔，很好。我当时说：“爸爸，爸爸，爸爸，放松。”他当时说：“没门，
you're gonna my face bill yeah I remember bill and bill was like new and bills just kept going I'm sorry man I yeah you know and I was like that like right there were your pairs were super nice oh it made me it I was gonna have a panic attack because I heard my I was had my back turned this is back when I smoked so I was having a cigarette that's right and I was and behind me I hear will our net bill senior and I was one time my mom went over and sat at Lawrence table and I look over there and Paul Rudd was like he kind of goes bill are you clocking this and I turn around and my mom is sitting at Lawrence
你就在我面前，比尔。”是的，我记得比尔，比尔当时是新人，比尔只是不停地说：“抱歉，伙计，我……”我当时想，就在那儿，你的父母超级好。哦，这让我……我要恐慌发作了，因为我听到我……我背对着，这是在我抽烟的时候，所以我当时在抽烟，没错。我身后听到威尔·阿奈特、比尔·斯尼尔，还有一次我妈妈走过去坐在洛恩的桌子旁，我往那边看，保罗·路德就像……他看着比尔说：“比尔，你注意到了吗？”我转过身，我妈妈正坐在洛恩的
table in between Marty short and Steven Spielberg over there and I'm like she's coming with me I'm sorry come on come on you know just like oh my god it's like they're all so short were you they're so tiny they're all so tiny were you I would imagine they're not even there in front of them yeah exactly were you confident that you were that you were a comedian and were able to make a living in comedy given that you were kind of just wanting to be a director and go that route and then all of a sudden you find yourself with a job as a comic it were you did you feel like great well
桌子旁，在马丁·肖特和史蒂文·斯皮尔伯格之间，我当时想：“她跟我一起来的，抱歉，快点，快点。”你知道，就像“哦天哪，他们都那么矮。”你是……他们太小了，他们都太小了。你是……我以为他们甚至不在他们面前。是的，完全正确。你当时自信你是一个喜剧演员，并且能够靠喜剧谋生吗？鉴于你当时只是想成为一名导演，走那条路，然后突然发现自己有一份喜剧演员的工作，你当时觉得……太棒了，好吧，
let's do this now are we like oh they're gonna find out yeah I don't know what I'm doing yeah yeah I was I mean to have that those people who were in there when I showed up you know I was really intimidated you know so I was like they all had second-city you know groundlings I mean I came in with Jason and yeah comedy Chicago man and I just was like I don't I remember my first table read just going I wrote a thing with Will Ornette sorry Will Forte and it was it was so bad and I just remember looking in the middle of it over at Tina Fey and she just had this look on her face like you know I was I was so I was very I was
现在我们开始吧，还是觉得“哦，他们会发现我什么都不知道的。”是的，是的，我是说，当我出现时，那些人都在那儿，我真的很胆怯，你知道，所以我当时想，他们都有第二城、地面剧团的背景，我的意思是，我和杰森一起进来的，是的，芝加哥喜剧，伙计，我只是……我不记得我的第一次剧本朗读，我写了一个东西，和威尔·阿奈特……抱歉，威尔·福特，它太糟糕了，我只记得在中间看着蒂娜·菲，她脸上那种表情，就像……你知道，我当时非常、非常
incredibly incredibly crippling insecure and anxious I would say the first four seasons but but it's almost like you were made for the show though because like I'm sorry to keep harping on the same point but it's like you you got this call but you could also you had all these characters inside of you and a lot of that's you know I find it rare in a lot of sketch shows that people have so many characters like you or Mike Myers or Dana Carvey or whoever that that just had them but did you even know that you had those characters in you no I didn't know no a lot of that was like you know you make fun of people you know you do
令人难以置信地极度不自信和焦虑，我想前四季都是这样。但几乎就像你是为这个节目而生的，因为……我很抱歉一直纠结于同一个点，但就像你接到了这个电话，但你也有，你内心有所有这些角色，而且很多……你知道，我发现很多小品节目中，人们有像你、迈克·迈尔斯、达纳·卡维或任何人那样拥有那么多角色是很罕见的，但你甚至知道你内心有那些角色吗？不，我不知道，不，很多就像……你知道，你取笑你认识的人，你做
impressions of people at school right you know things like that but never you know I don't know you guys are probably I don't know I was not the funniest of my friends in high school so it wasn't like I was known as a funny like my friends in high school when I hang out with them I'm like the eighth funniest guy right everyone you know how to cherry pick I know how to you know what I mean yeah half my shits all will our nets yeah Bill you know what makes me think of it is is our mutual friend and all of our friend the great Pete Serif in which when he used to do that 15 impressions but it's all of made-up
学校里的人的模仿，对吧？你知道类似的事情，但从来没有……我不知道，你们可能……我不知道，我在高中时不是朋友中最搞笑的，所以并不是说我被认为是一个搞笑的人。当我和高中朋友在一起时，我是第八搞笑的家伙，对吧？每个人……你知道如何精挑细选，我知道如何……你懂我意思吗？我的一半东西都是威尔·阿奈特的。比尔，你知道是什么让我想起这件事吗？是我们共同的朋友，我们所有人的朋友，伟大的皮特·塞拉菲诺维奇，当他过去做那15个模仿时，但全是虚构的
characters is one of my favorite things so it's not it's fake famous you guys both do an Alan Alda the kills you both do now well that's what people say Alan Alda was like we got to see Peter Serif I know what this is pretty insane but but bill it remember but you know it does make me think though like you did you talk about the film you did you in the lonely island boys started making video you were in there and working with those guys pretty early I mean in fact the summer after a lazy Sunday you guys were making hot rod was a June change it was a June July or August well that was September hot rod was August September
角色，这是我最喜欢的事情之一，所以这不是虚假的。你们俩都做一个艾伦·阿尔达，这会杀了你，你们俩现在都做。好吧，这就是人们说的，艾伦·阿尔达就像“我们得看看皮特·塞拉菲诺维奇。”我知道这很疯狂，但比尔，记得……但你知道，这确实让我想起……你谈到了你拍的电影，你和“孤独岛”那帮男孩开始拍视频，你在那儿，很早就和那些家伙一起工作。我的意思是，事实上，在《懒惰的周日》之后的那个夏天，你们在拍《热血大叔》，是六月、七月还是八月？那是九月，《热血大叔》是八月、九月
2006 that's fall 2006 that's just that it came out in seven yeah it came out in seven but it was shot and we shot it in six yeah cuz I remember I went up to my friends wedding in Toronto but I had to go really I was really sick I just we just want I just showed it I just watched that movie with my kids and their favorite part is you yelling babe babe babe which one is that hot rod I've not right remember there's that scene bill we were shooting it was you me Danny McBride and Yorm but you and Yorma were standing in front of me and and fuck I forget what happened I kept going like what about the little one we'd all
2006年，那是2006年秋天，那只是……它在7年上映，是的，它在7年上映，但它是拍摄的，我们在6年拍摄的。是的，因为我记得我去了我朋友在多伦多的婚礼，但我不得不去，我真的很生病，我只是……我们只是……我刚看了那部电影，和我孩子们一起，他们最喜欢的部分是你大喊“宝贝，宝贝，宝贝”，那是哪一部？《热血大叔》。我没有……记得有那个场景，比尔，我们在拍摄，是你、我、丹尼·麦克布莱德和约尔马，但你和约尔马站在我面前，该死，我忘了发生了什么，我一直说“那个小的怎么样？”我们都会
break up and I was like okay we gotta stop we gotta get one but what I was gonna say was you did you got on you started making videos with these guys really early and fuck I love the one that you guys did that fucking always kills me I think holds up is that dear sister oh yeah those I mean to be clear those guys wrote and directed all those it was kind of like they would come into my office and go hey Bill you want to be in this and I feel yes cuz I just wanted to be around them shooting stuff yeah but you're a vital part you're yeah that dear sister one was I think something fell through and that was a thing they
笑场，我说：“好吧，我们得停下来，我们得拍一条。”但我想说的是，你很早就开始和这些家伙拍视频了，该死，我喜欢你们拍的那个，那该死的总是让我笑死，我想经得起时间考验的是那个《亲爱的姐姐》，哦是的，那些……我的意思是，说清楚，那些家伙写并导演了所有那些。这有点像他们会走进我的办公室说：“嘿比尔，你想参与这个吗？”我感觉“是的”，因为我只是想和他们一起拍东西。是的，但你是重要的一部分，你是……那个《亲爱的姐姐》我觉得是有什么东西没成，那是他们
had done before so they're like oh we're gonna recreate this thing we did once before and that was at a hotel across the street from 30 Rock and all I remember from that one is that we started shooting it at like midnight no way and then it was done on Friday night and then it was done like seven in the morning Saturday morning and I walked out and I had the choice to like to like go home and try to sleep or do I just go to 30 Rock right now and just hang in my dressing room until we started rehearsing it was awful yeah I don't know but it was like it was you and Wig and Andy and Fred and Jason were cops
以前做过的事情，所以他们就像“哦，我们要重现我们以前做过一次的事情。”那是在30号洛克菲勒中心对面的一家酒店，关于那个我只记得我们是在午夜开始拍摄的，没可能，然后周五晚上就完成了，然后就像周六早上七点完成了。我走出来，我有选择，像回家试着睡觉，还是我现在就去30号洛克菲勒中心，在我的更衣室里待着，直到我们开始排练？这太糟糕了，是的，我不知道，但就像是你、威格、安迪、弗雷德和杰森是警察，
at the end and then Shia LaBeouf Shia LaBeouf and Fred and Jason you guys ever seen that sketch do yourselves a favor it is the Lonely Island guys incredible just incredible I'd love the timing of the editing of that sketch is unbelievably funny yeah it's very good it's a masterclass in timing yeah I got to see that and we will be right back smart list listener we get support from zip recruiter look I can juggle not very well but I can juggle I can speak French I can drive stick and I also can name all 50 capitals to all 50 states hey will what's the capital of Idaho
在最后，还有希亚·拉博夫，希亚·拉博夫和弗雷德和杰森。你们看过那个小品吗？帮自己一个忙，那是“孤独岛”那帮人，不可思议，简直不可思议。我喜欢那个小品剪辑的时间点，好笑得不可思议。是的，非常好，这是时间把握的大师课。是的，我得看看那个。我们马上回来，《SmartLess》听众，我们得到了ZipRecruiter的支持。看，我可以杂耍，虽然不太好，但我可以杂耍。我会说法语，我会开手动挡，我还能说出所有50个州的所有50个首府。嘿威尔，爱达荷州的首府是什么？
Idaho is Boise Nebraska Nebraska is Lincoln look the point is this from soft skills to hard skills it takes all kinds of talent to make a business successful so if you're hiring and you want to find the right combination of talent for your open roles it needs a recruiter and right now you can try it for free at zip recruiter comm slash smart list zip recruiter uses powerful technology to find and send you people whose skills and experience match your job just like I was highlighting about myself maybe that would be me for a certain role you never know if you see someone you're really interested in
爱达荷州是博伊西。内布拉斯加州？内布拉斯加州是林肯。看，重点是这个，从软技能到硬技能，需要各种各样的人才才能使企业成功。所以如果你在招聘，并且想为你的空缺职位找到合适的人才组合，你需要一个招聘人员。现在你可以在ZipRecruiter.com/smartless免费试用。ZipRecruiter使用强大的技术来寻找并向你发送技能和经验与你的工作相匹配的人，就像我刚才强调我自己的那样，也许那会是我，对于某个职位，你永远不知道。如果你看到你真正感兴趣的人，
zip recruiter lets you easily invite them to apply to your job to increase your chances of getting them before your competition does tap into zip recruiters unmatched talent for finding great candidates four out of five employers who post on zip recruiter get a quality candidate within the first day see for yourself go to this exclusive web address to try zip recruiter for free zip recruiter comm slash smart list again that's zip recruiter comm slash sm a RTL ESS zip recruiter the smartest way to hire smart list is brought to you in part by state farm your podcast feed is
ZipRecruiter让你轻松邀请他们申请你的工作，以增加你在竞争对手之前获得他们的机会。利用ZipRecruiter在寻找优秀候选人方面无与伦比的天赋。在ZipRecruiter上发布职位的雇主中，五分之四的人在第一天内就能获得高质量的候选人。亲自看看，前往这个独家网址免费试用ZipRecruiter。ZipRecruiter.com/smartless，再次强调，那是ZipRecruiter.com/smartless。ZipRecruiter，最聪明的招聘方式。《SmartLess》部分由State Farm赞助。你的播客订阅是
fantastic because it contains only what you want like smart list obvi and nothing else because life is just better when you can personalize your experience personalization means you have the power to choose what you want to include and leave out what you don't it just feels better when you have that kind of control and that's the kind of control we all crave man that's what we're looking for that's the actual that's the nectar of life hmm hang on let me Google that might not be the nectar of life point is why shouldn't insurance work like that too that's what the state farm personal
极好的，因为它只包含你想要的内容，比如《SmartLess》，显而易见，没有别的。因为当你能个性化你的体验时，生活会更好。个性化意味着你有权选择你想要包含的内容，并排除你不想要的内容。当你拥有那种控制权时，感觉会更好，那是我们所有人都渴望的控制权，伙计，那是我们正在寻找的。那是生活的花蜜。嗯，等一下，让我谷歌一下，那可能不是生活的花蜜。重点是，为什么保险不能那样运作呢？这就是State Farm个人
price plan is all about you can choose to include options like bundling your home and auto policies which means you'll get the coverage you want at an affordable price just for you in the end you'll have a policy that gives you what you want doesn't that feel better like a good neighbor state farm is there call or go to state farm dot com today to create your state farm personal price plan prices vary by state options selected by customer availability and eligibility may vary this episode of smart list is brought to you in part by Macy's are you are you like me are you scrambling to get a gift
价格计划的全部内容。你可以选择包含诸如捆绑你的房屋和汽车保单之类的选项，这意味着你将以实惠的价格获得你想要的保险，专为你而设。最终，你将拥有一份给你想要的东西的保单，那感觉不是更好吗？像个好邻居，State Farm就在那里。今天就致电或访问StateFarm.com创建你的State Farm个人价格计划。价格因州而异，客户选择的选项、可用性和资格可能会有所不同。本期《SmartLess》部分由梅西百货赞助。你像我一样吗？你是否在匆忙为
for Mother's Day by the way it's on Sunday the 14th of May Macy's makes it so easy to tailor your gift hunt to mom's tastes with their gift finder check out these great ways to shop and more inspo at Macy's comm slash gift finder yeah bless you thank you sorry I'm just I'm allergic to not finding the gifts I want if you already know that mom loves adding to her handbag collection or a doors matching PJ set or is looking for a new signature scent you can shop by gift category or shop by gift lists Macy's has unique curated gift lists like for the mom who has everything or gifts that are already wrapped and ready
母亲节买礼物？顺便说一句，是在5月14日星期日。梅西百货让根据妈妈的品味定制礼物搜索变得如此简单，使用他们的礼物搜索器。在Macys.com/giftfinder查看这些很棒的购物方式和更多灵感。是的，保佑你，谢谢。抱歉，我只是对找不到我想要的礼物过敏。如果你已经知道妈妈喜欢增加她的手提包收藏，或者喜欢配套的睡衣套装，或者正在寻找一种新的标志性香水，你可以按礼物类别购物或按礼物清单购物。梅西百货有独特的精选礼物清单，比如为拥有了一切的妈妈准备的，或者已经包装好准备
to be gifted and for grandma and if mom loves designer names find the latest from her most adored brands whether she's loyal to coach handbags Dior perfume or Godiva chocolates Macy's has all her top faves that's one of those things that that I got to get in there I got to go and use the list at Macy's because now knowing that they have this thing this gift finder I know it's gonna be so much easier for me because I'm just such a last-minuteer and it sometimes feels overwhelming and it's tough because buying something for your mom it just feels so huge because she's your mom how do you think your mom you
送出的礼物。还有为祖母准备的。如果妈妈喜欢设计师品牌，可以找到她最崇拜品牌的最新产品。无论她是忠于蔻驰手提包、迪奥香水还是歌帝梵巧克力，梅西百货都有她所有的最爱。这是我必须进去做的事情之一，我必须去使用梅西百货的清单，因为现在知道他们有这个东西，这个礼物搜索器，我知道对我来说会容易得多，因为我总是最后一刻才买，有时感觉不知所措，这很难，因为为你妈妈买东西感觉太重大了，因为她是你的妈妈。你怎么想你妈妈，你
can't do it enough but with Macy's gift finder it just it just makes it so much easier head on over to Macy's comm slash gift finder to make this mother's day and especially memorable one that's Macy's comm slash gift finder and now back to the show so Bill did you did you think that you had a fastball when you started was was there did you think I'm gonna do impersonations or I'm gonna be the straight man or I'm gonna be crazy like what did you think like your Vincent right by the way your Vincent price fucking kills thank you yeah a lot of stuff was the writers would kind of I was someone who really needed the
怎么做都不够，但有了梅西百货的礼物搜索器，它让一切变得容易多了。前往Macys.com/giftfinder，让这个母亲节变得特别难忘。那是Macys.com/giftfinder。现在回到节目。所以比尔，你认为你刚开始的时候有快球吗？有没有……你认为“我要做模仿，或者我要做直男，或者我要做疯子”，你认为你是什么？比如你的文森特·普莱斯，该死，太棒了，谢谢。很多东西是编剧会……我是一个真正需要
writers I was always impressed with people like Fred and Kristen and these people who just write for themselves yeah you know and you were like man you guys are just so confident you could do that I really need to go into a writer and go you know and sometimes it was like well Bill what's a voice you do you know it's anything and and like a lot of people I kind of came in and my heroes and things I liked was much more weirder and kind of stranger and a lot of I learned the term hat on a hat yeah it was like I was like you can't just do a talk show it's got to be a talk show that's inside a man's ear that's on the
编剧的人。我总是对像弗雷德和克里斯汀这些人印象深刻，他们只是为自己写作，是的，你知道，你当时想“伙计，你们太自信了，你们能做到。”我真的需要去找一个编剧，然后说……有时就像“好吧，比尔，你有什么声音可以做？”你知道，任何东西。像很多人一样，我进来时，我的英雄和我喜欢的东西更古怪，更奇怪，很多……我学会了“帽子上的帽子”这个词，是的，就像我当时想“你不能只是做一个脱口秀，它必须是一个在男人耳朵里的脱口秀，在……”
you know whatever it was very money Python explain explain had on a hat for the it's kind of like a joke on a joke so a perfect example was I did a sketch because I could do a tauntaun impression it's so funny and Mike Matt Murray one of the great writers on the show said what if you did that they're banter and we so you so and we had Natalie Portman was hosting so it's like oh what if it's you teaching her how to do different Star Wars noises as part of her SNL audition and then I said what if I do it is Peter Falk so what that thing alone is me as just an acting teacher yeah that's enough uh-huh but adding Peter
你知道，无论它是什么，它非常像蒙提·派森。解释一下“帽子上的帽子”是什么意思？这有点像笑话上的笑话。一个完美的例子是我做了一个小品，因为我可以做塔斯肯袭击者的模仿，太搞笑了。迈克·马特·默里，节目组伟大的编剧之一，说：“如果你那样做会怎样？”他们的玩笑，我们……所以你……我们有娜塔莉·波特曼主持，所以就像“哦，如果这是你教她如何做不同的星球大战声音，作为她《周六夜现场》试镜的一部分会怎样？”然后我说：“如果我把它做成彼得·福克会怎样？”所以那个东西本身就是我作为一个表演老师，是的，这就够了。嗯哼，但加上彼得·
Falk was like can you do like two seconds of it on a hat oh no it was like so yeah this is a job now listen the tauntaun comes from the landed horse come over here will holding his eye Luke Skywalker is gonna have to ride him across the icy and and and and I just remember Seth Meyer is going like hey buddy hey buddy can I talk to you for a second how it's a little bit of a hat on a hat and I go what and then I did it at dress you're never gonna believe this it died as well as we I could hear my footsteps I could hear myself put in
福克就像“你能做两秒钟吗？”帽子上的帽子，哦不，它就像……所以是的，这是一份工作。现在听着，塔斯肯袭击者来自……过来，威尔捂着他的眼睛，卢克·天行者将不得不骑着他穿过冰冷的……而且……而且……我只记得塞斯·迈耶斯说：“嘿伙计，嘿伙计，我能跟你谈谈吗？”它有点像帽子上的帽子。我说：“什么？”然后我在彩排时做了，你永远不会相信，它也死了，就像我们……我能听到我的脚步声，我能听到我自己放下
a glass of water down it was like so quiet you can hear the e-train you hear someone cough in the alphabet streets and I was like oh god this is bad news and uh and and I went in there and I just looked at me and he might not mimicked you know putting a hat on top of another hat and I was like okay and so it didn't make it yeah I think that is so funny was Natalie must have been dying when you were doing yeah she I think she seemed to like it I don't know and then and then we did I remember Dana Carvey hosted we did a thing called the casems where he was Casey case and I was the son JC case him and the whole thing
一杯水的声音，它太安静了，你能听到E线地铁，你能听到有人在字母街咳嗽，我当时想“哦天哪，这是坏消息。”然后……然后我进去，他只是看着我，他可能模仿了（你）把一顶帽子放在另一顶帽子上，我当时想“好吧。”所以它没成功。是的，我认为那太搞笑了。娜塔莉一定在你做的时候笑死了。是的，我想她似乎喜欢它，我不知道。然后……然后我们做了，我记得达纳·卡维主持，我们做了一个叫“凯瑟姆一家”的东西，他是凯西·凯瑟姆，我是儿子JC·凯瑟姆，整个事情
was that we had a terrible relationship and it was me coming to the house at two in the morning and he was like who's out there I'm Casey case I'm like it's dad it's not a burglar raccoon it's me your son JC case son get out of here dad here me out son I want nothing to do with you and it was this very intense family drama you're always asking me why won't you get a job why will you won't you stop doing drugs and what recording orders had more number one is Mariah Carrey with 11 but seriously son I need you out of my house and that played to utter silence I've got more silence because the audience was going wait did
是我们关系很糟糕，是我凌晨两点回家，他就像“谁在那儿？我是凯西·凯瑟姆。”我说：“是爸爸，不是窃贼浣熊，是我，你的儿子JC·凯瑟姆。”“儿子，走开。”“爸爸，听我说。”“儿子，我不想和你有什么关系。”这是一个非常激烈的家庭剧。你总是问我为什么不找工作，为什么不停止吸毒，什么记录订单，第一名是玛丽亚·凯莉，有11首，但说真的，儿子，我需要你离开我的房子。那演出来一片死寂。我得到了更多的沉默，因为观众在想“等等，他……等等，什么？”你知道我意思吗？所以……是的，我们只是……我本来会和达纳一起，达纳和我当时想“为什么……我和约翰·穆兰尼写的。”我们俩都想“为什么那没成功？”好吧，你们有没有讨论过……因为彩排是八点，然后节目显然是……是的，11点半。但有没有……你有没有说过“好吧，八点的观众很奇怪，他们不一样，让我们相信11点半的观众会在家里喜欢它。”而且……就像它不是……我希望有一个科学依据，但我确实记得如果彩排很火，那很糟糕。如果彩排非常
he wait what you know what I mean and so and yeah we were just I would have been on Dana and I were going Dana and I were like why didn't I wrote it with John Mulaney and we both were like why didn't that work well do you guys ever have discussions about well because the dress is what eight and then the show is obviously yeah and 30 but is there a do you ever say well but the audience at eight is weird and it's different let's just trust that the 1130 audience is gonna love it at home and and it's like it's not I wish there was a science to it but it I do remember if the dress was hot that was bad if dress was really
火，我记得波勒说：“哦，彩排很火，那很糟糕。”我当时想“为什么？什么？”哦，你知道，然后……是的，没错。就像如果彩排很火，那么奇怪的是你会得到……这是一种迷信，你会变得非常自信，然后当你出去做现场直播时，就像“去吧，去吧。”我想说的是，对于我的妹妹特雷西，当你说是彩排时……彩排，哦抱歉，你在预演现场直播之前做的，抱歉，我在彩排中有额外的小品，是的，所以有一个剪辑，继续，它没用，被删掉了，是的。所以彩排是在八点，我们做整个节目，加上……我记得有三四个
hot I remember pollers saying like oh hot dress that's bad and I was like why what oh you know and then yes right it's like if the dress is hot then weirdly you get like it's a superstition thing you get really confident and then when you go out to do the live show it's like go shot go shot I was to say for my sister Tracy like when you say dress is dress rehearsal oh sorry that you do before the pre-show live show sorry I have extra sketches in the dress yes so there's a cut go ahead it doesn't work gets paired out yeah so dress rehearsals at eight o'clock we do a whole show plus like I remember that three or four
额外的小品，然后我们去洛恩的办公室，东西被剪掉了，东西被重新安排和重写了，然后那是现场直播。这是在与主持人进行简短交谈之后，他们可以插话，我不确定效果如何，关于他们想要什么或不想要什么，是的，我不确定他们是否在听。我想……那是洛恩在吃爆米花，说：“是的，我的意思是，如果你想看起来像个傻瓜，我们可以这样做。”你知道，我曾经……我姐夫曾经打过一次高尔夫，是的，几年前，他拥有一家高尔夫俱乐部，问题是你是要租还是拥有，你是要……你知道，而且
extra sketches and then we go into Lauren's office and stuff has been cut and then the stuff's been rearranged and rewritten and then that's the live show and this is after a brief conversation with the host who gets to chime in I'm not sure to what effect about what they would like or not yeah and I'm not sure if they're listening I think and it's Lauren eating popcorn going yeah I mean if you want to look like a fool we can do this you know I once I once my brother-in-law played golf once yes years ago and he owned a golf club and the question is are you gonna rent her own are you gonna catch is you know and
额外的草稿，然后我们走进劳伦的办公室，有些内容被删减了，有些被重新编排和改写，这就是现场表演。这发生在一场简短的对话之后，主持人可以插话——我不确定效果如何——表达他们想要什么或不想要什么。是的，我不确定他们是否在听，我想那是劳伦在吃爆米花，一边说：‘好吧，如果你想看起来像个傻瓜，我们可以这样做。’你知道，我曾经……我姐夫多年前打过一次高尔夫球，他有一根高尔夫球杆，问题是你打算租还是买，你打算……你知道的。
then you we would do those Vincent Price sketches and if you between dress and hair and like someone wouldn't do something you know old-school impression and Lauren would be like what if John Hamm played Herbert Marshall and you're hearing the band playing you're hearing the live audience be put in and you're like I don't know if the audience is gonna know Fred McMurray and it's like how about James Mason anybody could you do if I imagine you when you're working on an impression if I imagined you in front of a mirror alone just like making faces and doing sounds is that is that is that about the extent of it like is
然后我们就会做那些文森特·普莱斯的短剧，如果你在化妆和发型之间，或者有人不配合，你知道那种老派的模仿，劳伦就会说，如果乔·汉姆扮演赫伯特·马歇尔会怎样，你听着乐队在演奏，听着现场观众的笑声被加进去，你会想，我不知道观众是否认识弗雷德·麦克默里，就像詹姆斯·梅森怎么样，如果我想象你在练习模仿时，想象你独自在镜子前做鬼脸和发声，大概就是这样，是吗？
it a real private kind of or is it kind of a little here and a little there like sometimes in the car sometimes in the car you do it around people and then it kind of comes out and it's like whoa that's not a good do you still do that bill or I mean do you still oh yeah yeah it's like it's just like yeah it's like a my dad does this to where it's a it's called appropriation where it's you know when you're nervous around someone you start to talk like them you know and I've done that since I was a kid like a very socially anxious and then you start to mimic people's accents as a way of being like hey I'm like don't you know
这是一种非常私人的事情，还是说这里一点那里一点，就像有时在车里，有时在车里你会在别人面前做，然后它就冒出来了，就像哇，那不太好，比尔，你还那样做吗？或者我是说你还，哦，是的，是的，就像，就像我爸爸也这样做，这叫“挪用”，就是当你和某人在一起感到紧张时，你开始像他们一样说话，你知道，我从小就这样，非常社交焦虑，然后你开始模仿别人的口音，作为一种“嘿，我和你一样，你知道吗”的方式。
like we're all good you know it's like we're part of the same tribe don't kill me yeah don't don't kill me so yeah you start to talk like people or whatever and then and so I think that went itself to being able to do voices you know when you were growing up in Oklahoma did you do that with like did you have a did you gravitate towards friends that had the same sensibility and we're kind of yeah you know I'd like that or were you like oh yeah and like we weren't like weird outcast no he was trying to ingratiate himself with murderers and well that too I mean yeah I mean I kind of wanted like oh I just wanted like to get to know
就像我们都很好，你知道，就像我们是同一个部落的，别杀我，是的，别杀我，所以是的，你开始像别人一样说话什么的，所以我认为这有助于模仿声音，你知道，当你在俄克拉荷马州长大时，你有没有那样做，比如你是否倾向于和有同样感性的人交朋友，或者你是否像，哦，是的，我们不是那种奇怪的局外人，不，他是在试图讨好杀人犯，嗯，那也是，我是说，我只是想了解。
everybody yeah no but like my best friend is a writer on Barry is like one of the big writers on Barry and we've known each other since we were 15 or so wow we still right great show and you're great yeah congrats so working on a bridge from SNL to Barry what about do you remember the moment where it started to become clear to you that okay my life is changing and going to change and I gotta kind of get my knees bent and be ready for what can be pretty uncomfortable which is fame and recognition and responsibility and and and approaching your dreams what did that feel like when Barry came out or like when after SNL
每个人，是的，不，但我最好的朋友是《巴瑞》的编剧，是《巴瑞》的主要编剧之一，我们从15岁左右就认识了，哇，我们还在写很棒的剧，你也很棒，是的，恭喜，所以从《周六夜现场》到《巴瑞》的过渡，你还记得什么时候开始清楚地意识到，好吧，我的生活正在改变，并将要改变，我得弯下膝盖，准备好迎接可能相当不舒服的事情，那就是名声、认可、责任，以及接近你的梦想，当《巴瑞》出来时，或者在《周六夜现场》之后，那是什么感觉？
ended yeah I mean to move away now from SNL but I guess it must have started there and and feeling like maybe I can now leave and see if I've got what I hope I have and try it out there yeah that's that's it's nerve-wracking when you I mean because I remember when I left SNL I did like interviews about it like I went and did like Charlie Rose and I did these things about you're leaving SNL and the attitude and everything was like well maybe we're never gonna see you again you know nice knowing you that's the rest great no one knows there's you know and it was like maybe that's it and so yeah it was I wonder what that batting
结束了，是的，我是说现在离开《周六夜现场》，但我想它一定是从那里开始的，感觉好像我现在可以离开，看看我是否拥有我所希望拥有的东西，并在外面尝试一下，是的，那是令人伤脑筋的，因为我记得我离开《周六夜现场》时，我做了一些关于它的采访，比如我去了查理·罗斯的节目，我做了这些关于你离开《周六夜现场》的事情，态度和一切都像是，好吧，也许我们再也见不到你了，你知道，很高兴认识你，那是其余的，没人知道，你知道，就像也许就是这样，所以我很好奇那个击球。
average is what do you what do you think the percentage of cast members that go on to you know careers that you can you can still make a living with I don't know I mean yeah I have no idea I mean I I try to I think it was for me it was like you know it's like if I thought of like what makes the plane stay up in the air I would go crazy yeah you know so so I just was like I'm just gonna move forward and block out any sort of because I'm very sensitive to other people's energy so it is hard when you see you know agents or executives are like hi you know wait am I out I mean wait what was that
平均水平是多少，你认为继续从事你能维持生计的职业的演员比例是多少？我不知道，我是说，我不知道，我是说我试着，我想对我来说，就像，如果我想到是什么让飞机保持在空中，我会疯掉的，是的，你知道，所以我只是想，我只是要继续前进，屏蔽掉任何，因为我对别人的能量非常敏感，所以当你看到经纪人或高管说“嗨，你知道，等等，我出局了吗？我是说，等等，那是什么？”时，这很难。
and so I'm very so I I do kind of like put my head down and just keep moving forward and try stuff it was pretty cool to see you start taking roles that weren't necessarily starring roles they were these really cool supporting roles in in these really fun movies that had these great big stars leading them and I was like this this is it looks like you're building this foundation that is gonna be around for a long time and then when Barry happened and especially the directing element I was just like so excited for you and then talking with you afterwards and finding out about your original passion which was directing
所以我非常，所以我确实有点低着头，只是继续前进，尝试一些事情，看到你开始接那些不一定是主角的角色，而是那些在由大明星领衔的非常有趣的电影中非常酷的配角，这真的很酷，我当时想，这看起来你正在建立一个将长期存在的基础，然后当《巴瑞》发生时，特别是导演元素，我为你感到非常兴奋，然后事后和你交谈，发现你最初的热情是导演。
I just was so excited for you that that has all come true I mean thank you very much jumping around a bit but I mean it was that always a goal for you and that some of these to the extent there was any strategy that some of these these career choices were meant to point you in that direction and finally land something where you could be somewhat of an auteur yeah I mean I think it was always wanted to do movies and then and then you know I'd written some scripts and then I was did some acting jobs and then but I didn't really have a lot of faith in myself it was kind of like you know it's like you dream of a thing but
我只是为你感到非常兴奋，这一切都实现了，我是说，非常感谢，跳跃一点，但我是说，那一直是你追求的目标吗？在某种程度上，如果有什么策略的话，这些职业选择是否旨在引导你朝着那个方向发展，并最终获得一些你可以成为某种作者的东西？是的，我是说，我想我一直想拍电影，然后，你知道，我写了一些剧本，然后我做了一些表演工作，然后，但我对自己真的没有太大的信心，就像，你知道，你梦想着一件事，但。
you don't you know I don't know if I can do it feels like the universe wants me to be this thing right and I'm kind of going well maybe I'm not right for this other thing and then honestly I had a beanie with HBO they had seen me in a movie called Skeleton Twins and they said oh you should yeah we were interested in you being like that kind of acting in a show for us not like sketch and I was like okay cool and then they know you meet this guy Alec Berg maybe you guys come up with something so Alec and I sat Alec Berg came up with with the show Barry and it was when I went into the meeting I talked about Alec about it or
你不知道，我不知道我是否能做到，感觉宇宙想让我成为这样的人，对吧，而我有点在想，也许我不适合做别的事情，然后老实说，我和HBO有个会面，他们看过我演的一部叫《骨肉同谋》的电影，他们说，哦，你应该，是的，我们对你像那样在我们的节目中表演感兴趣，不是像小品，我说，好吧，酷，然后他们知道你认识这个叫亚历克·伯格的人，也许你们能想出点什么，所以亚历克和我坐下来，亚历克·伯格想出了《巴瑞》这部剧，当我走进会议室时，我和亚历克谈过它，或者。
anybody and they went who do you think should do the pilot Michael and Bartos like who do you think should do the pilot and I was like I'll direct it and it was just silence and like if you were directed before I was like no no but I can do it and Alec Berg to his credit kind of looked at me I didn't talk to him about it or anything and he went yeah yeah he can do it yeah I got no he'll be you can do it and then that's great and then he told me afterwards that he was driving home and they called him going all right can you really do it or you do this yeah cuz that's a big for Tracy that's a very good you tell me though at
任何人，他们问，你认为谁应该执导试播集？迈克尔和巴托斯就像，你认为谁应该执导试播集？我说，我来执导，然后是一片沉默，就像你以前执导过吗？我说，没有，但我能做到，亚历克·伯格值得称赞，他看了我一眼，我没跟他谈过这个，他说，是的，是的，他能做到，是的，我没有，不，他会，你能做到，然后那太棒了，然后他事后告诉我，他开车回家时，他们打电话给他，说，好吧，他真的能做到吗？或者你做这个，是的，因为这对特雷西来说，那是一个非常好的，你告诉我，虽然在。
one time and maybe that you said that Alec said to HBO yes if Jason Bateman can direct anybody can is that yeah that is a quote that's yeah well that was a t-shirt they wear over the DJ that was a tee and the DJ said the DJ said yeah we let him in as a as a bit they said they said yeah yeah into the DJ also at South by Southwest when they give you your key cards yeah before seasons it's like if Jason Bateman that's what guys this I hope this is a joke no it's gonna be it's a big long joke and they're giving you awards and they're giving you jobs because at the end it's gonna be we're gonna do a big reveal when you're
一次，也许你说过亚历克对HBO说，如果杰森·贝特曼能执导，任何人都能，是吗？是的，那是一句名言，那是他们穿在DJ身上的T恤，那是件T恤，DJ说，DJ说，是的，我们让他进来作为一种噱头，他们说，他们说，是的，是的，进入DJ，也在西南偏南电影节，当他们给你钥匙卡时，是的，在几季之前，就像如果杰森·贝特曼，这就是伙计们，我希望这是一个玩笑，不，它会是一个很长的玩笑，他们给你奖项，他们给你工作，因为最后，它会是一个大揭秘，当你。
like 60 yeah and by the way when Jason 60 he's simultaneously gonna weigh 60 pounds he's whittling down you know and now we can even have the nuts so it's just the cardboard so it's gonna be 60 pounds and then we all go it was a fucking joke Jason do you ever have that happen though when people look at you and they go oh actor and actors directing if they don't I'm they can always be sure that I'm doing it I'm sitting there going what what am I yeah but both you guys are smart dudes and you know what you're doing and you've been around a lot and as you know from the little directing that I've done it's it's a
60岁时，是的，顺便说一句，当杰森60岁时，他会同时体重60磅，他在消瘦，你知道，现在我们甚至可以有坚果，所以只是纸板，所以会是60磅，然后我们都说，那是个该死的玩笑，杰森，你有没有遇到过这种情况，当人们看着你，他们说，哦，演员，演员在执导，如果他们不，我，他们总是可以确定我在做，我坐在那里想，什么，我是什么，是的，但你们两个都是聪明的家伙，你知道你在做什么，你经历了很多，正如你从我做过的一点点导演工作中知道的那样，它是。
much more about understanding what it is that you want tonally and what you want that to be and also you guys have succeeded in it it's not like you tried it and failed but still it doesn't matter because my idea of what a director is and looks like is completely opposite for me it's just like your idea of what 50 would be when you were 12 has nothing to do with what I feel like and look like at 50 or you know like you also know like even the greats as you know there is a certain and I say this out of you know with a tremendous amount of respect for all the great directors that have come out is is there's that thing
更多的是关于理解你在音调上想要什么，以及你想要它成为什么，而且你们都成功了，并不是说你们尝试了却失败了，但即便如此，这并不重要，因为我对导演是什么和看起来像什么的看法完全相反，对我来说，这就像你12岁时对50岁是什么样子的想法，和我50岁时的感觉和样子毫无关系，或者你知道，就像你也知道，即使是伟大的导演，正如你所知，有一种特定的，我怀着对所有伟大的导演的极大尊重说这句话，那就是。
of like they have to keep it special and keep it exclusive and keep you out because it they're not doing it to punish everybody else but it's also to maintain that respect and that level of thing it's like this guy's a great director and you could never do that and there's a little bit of like well you did it no you're just a human being as well and yeah it's not so scary just a bit yeah a little bit and there is and of course there are great directors but you guys are both very accomplished good directors and you that's how you become a great as you keep doing it yeah and also just sitting around a set and
就像他们必须保持它的特殊性，保持它的排他性，把你挡在外面，因为他们这样做不是为了惩罚其他人，但这也是为了保持那种尊重和那种水平，就像这家伙是个伟大的导演，你永远做不到，有一点点，好吧，你做到了，不，你也是一个人，是的，没那么可怕，只是有点，是的，有一点，当然有伟大的导演，但你们两个都是非常有成就的好导演，这就是你成为伟大的方式，因为你一直在做，是的，还有只是坐在片场，。
absorbing what everybody is doing to create this fake world like it's hard what these crew members do is insane insane it's really really and it's not just the director as you guys know it right there everybody the costume department look how many actors show up on the first day of principle photography and they're like okay let's get started I think no no we've been to this we've been doing this probably a half a dozen times already basically yeah it's always yeah people kind of thinking like well you know I mean it's also I always have a thing where you have an idea and then you go out there and you
吸收每个人正在做的事情来创造这个虚假的世界，这很难，这些剧组成员所做的事情是疯狂的，疯狂的，它真的，真的，而且不仅仅是导演，正如你们所知，对吧，每个人，服装部门，看看有多少演员在主要摄影的第一天出现，他们说，好吧，让我们开始吧，我想，不，不，我们已经，我们已经这样做了大概六次了，基本上，是的，总是，是的，人们有点认为，好吧，你知道，我是说，我也总是有个想法，然后你走出去，你。
see all these people busting their ass away from their families yeah in terrible conditions for at least 12 hours trying to make you right you're trying to make your idea happen you know I mean I'm like I sit and I look at that I feel like such a responsibility to you know have my shit together and and as we know as actors that's the worst is when you have a director that doesn't know what they want and they're certainly and it can be this and you're there for I mean I've worked on shows where I did a show on a movie where we did reverse splits because we kept going so late through the week so by Friday we started the day on stage
看到所有这些人为了你的想法，在可怕的条件下，远离家人，拼命工作至少12个小时，你知道，我是说，我坐着看，我感到一种责任，你知道，把我的事情处理好，而且正如我们作为演员所知道的，最糟糕的是当你有一个不知道自己想要什么的导演，他们当然，它可以是这样，你就在那里，我是说，我参与过一些节目，我在一部电影里做过反向轮班，因为我们一周工作太晚，所以到周五，我们在舞台上开始了一天。
at 1 a.m. yeah shot until 3 p.m. on stage because a director because a director was just like I don't know what's reverse what's reverse splits okay so like for Tracy that's a big treasure yeah so like if you start like so you have to have like a like certain people have to have like 12 hour turnarounds meaning like if you work from 7 a.m. and you you shoot until 10 p.m. you got to start the next day at 10 a.m. right give people 12 hours you get 12 hours of rest which includes driving home which is exactly can't negotiate you got to negotiate that no but I mean early on when you're starting that's let's not even get into
在凌晨1点，是的，拍到下午3点，在舞台上，因为一个导演，因为一个导演只是说，我不知道什么是反向，什么是反向轮班，好吧，所以对特雷西来说，那是一个大宝藏，是的，所以如果你开始，所以你必须有，比如某些人必须有12小时的周转时间，意思是如果你从早上7点工作，你拍到晚上10点，你必须在第二天早上10点开始，对吧，给人们12小时，你得到12小时的休息，包括开车回家，这完全是不能谈判的，你必须谈判那个，不，但我是说，早期当你开始时，让我们甚至不要进入。
portal to portal I mean what are you talking about a portal to portal is like the goal like you got portal to portal wait now we're gonna start getting into Downey's deal I mean Downey's on stage for 45 minutes before he's out yeah it's anyway you go to so like if you start at you know Monday at work at 7 a.m. and you end at 10 p.m. and then you have to go okay now we have 10 a.m. and then they go to tell one now Wednesday you can't start until 1 p.m. and then you can't learn 1 p.m. it's gonna roll back even more so it's basically a director shooting 18 to 20 hour days and you got to get people there turn around it just
门到门，我是说你在说什么，门到门就像目标，你得到了门到门，等等，现在我们要开始进入唐尼的交易了，我是说唐尼在舞台上待了45分钟才出来，是的，总之，所以如果你开始，你知道周一早上7点工作，你晚上10点结束，然后你必须去，好吧，现在我们有早上10点，然后他们去告诉一点，现在周三你不能在下午1点之前开始，然后你不能在下午1点之前学习，它会回滚更多，所以基本上是一个导演拍摄18到20小时，你必须让人周转，它只是。
keeps pushing pushing pushing right so so you're ending your work week Saturday Friday for in the afternoon yeah Friday and you're like yeah yeah yeah and it's solely because someone doesn't have their shit together yeah shit and then director's defense they never see any other director direct so they don't know that they're not getting it done that they're not doing it well it's you know actors crew members everybody sees multiple directors and then if you ever get the chance to direct you can cherry pick from all the good ones exactly do the stuff that the bad guys did Sean go ahead jump in it's a quick I wanted to
一直推，推，推，对吧，所以你周五下午结束你的工作周，是的，周五，你就像，是的，是的，是的，这完全是因为有人没有把他们的工作做好，是的，该死，然后导演的辩护，他们从没见过其他导演执导，所以他们不知道他们没有完成，他们做得不好，你知道，演员、剧组成员，每个人都见过多个导演，然后如果你有机会执导，你可以从所有好的导演那里挑选，完全做那些坏家伙做的事情，肖恩，继续，跳进来，这是一个快速的，我想。
say Bill one of the first times I was ever introduced it introduced to one of those hysterical bad lip reading things was you somebody sent it to me years ago and they're so funny I think there were Star Wars ones or something yeah and and and they make me go so I never seen that and I want to know are you done you're done with the subject we were on yeah directing okay he loves he loves it he's just goes 180 on unbelievable he got it it's okay it's fine you've pissed off the guest Sean no no it's okay we can talk about bad lip reading no I always wanted to know because I know I've never met anybody
说，比尔，我第一次被介绍给那些歇斯底里的“糟糕的唇读”视频之一时，是你，有人几年前发给我的，它们太搞笑了，我想有《星球大战》的或者什么的，是的，而且它们让我去，所以我从没见过那个，我想知道，你做完了吗？我们讨论的主题，是的，导演，好吧，他喜欢，他喜欢它，他只是180度大转弯，难以置信，他明白了，没关系，没关系，你惹恼了嘉宾，肖恩，不，不，没关系，我们可以谈谈“糟糕的唇读”，不，我一直想知道，因为我知道我从没见过任何人。
who I know who did it how I just got a dumbest question the world but I'm always interested in knowing how do you do it did they just run the tape and you ad lib or the guy who does it is a genius and he he just you go to his house and he's done it already oh wow so you just you just oh you just it's you are it's just oh okay watching it going okay so he's done it already and so you're trying to mimic it's so funny they've done and it's really that guy and it kind of just took off and now they do it for people in Congress and like I don't know how they yeah I have no idea anyway that's all I want to know now what we
我知道谁做的，我只是问了一个世界上最愚蠢的问题，但我一直对知道你是怎么做到的很感兴趣，他们只是运行磁带，你即兴发挥，还是做这个的人是个天才，他，你只是去他家，他已经做好了，哦，哇，所以你只是，你只是，哦，你只是，哦，好吧，看着它，说，好吧，所以他已经做好了，所以你试图模仿，太搞笑了，他们做到了，而且真的是那个人，它有点起飞了，现在他们为国会的人做这个，就像，我不知道他们怎么，是的，我不知道，总之，这就是我想知道的全部，现在我们。
move this around in the episode I mean there's a whole Sean section that is after we say he's like a make-a-wish kid he'll just go I was wanting to know how didn't you and when we give him a t-shirt every once in a while we're just building the steam with the juke row up with a dog now with with Barry where are we with where are we with Barry as we as we talk I know by the way sorry no offense to make a wish obviously it's an amazing and yeah you have to say that everybody knows your job okay well we don't you know we get lots of letters from people let them let them write just don't read
在这一集中移动这个，我是说，有一个完整的肖恩部分，在我们说他像个“许愿”孩子之后，他只是会去，我一直想知道你是怎么做的，当我们偶尔给他一件T恤时，我们只是在用点唱机和狗增加动力，现在用《巴瑞》，我们在哪里，我们在哪里，当我们谈论《巴瑞》时，我知道顺便说一句，抱歉，对“许愿”没有冒犯，显然这是一个了不起的，是的，你必须说每个人都知道你的工作，好吧，我们不知道，你知道，我们收到很多人的来信，让他们写，只是不要读。
them well you're right yeah but so where are we with with Barry are we in production out of production the thing with Barry I'm just waiting for Sean to come in yeah it was really funny he doesn't think of any questions until you're actually talking your parents listen to Charo believe me it's exactly like that no but I think that's funny I like that no we just did so we're doing editing season four and how high can you jump I'm just curious these are the things seem like you could long legs you could jump high anyway depression you were talking about depression you're really into the you're really into the
他们，好吧，你是对的，是的，但那么我们在《巴瑞》方面进展如何？我们在制作中，还是在制作外？关于《巴瑞》的事情，我只是在等肖恩进来，是的，这真的很有趣，他直到你真正说话时才想到任何问题，你父母听查罗的，相信我，完全是那样，不，但我认为这很有趣，我喜欢那样，不，我们刚刚做了，所以我们正在剪辑第四季，你能跳多高？我只是好奇，这些事情看起来你可能有长腿，你可以跳得很高，总之，抑郁，你在谈论抑郁，你真的很投入。
thing you were talking about but I just wanted to take you out just to satisfy this my own itch and so that's right depression has affected your family for how long and and and you do like tater tots I just want to get that and now a word from our sponsor smart list is supported by Benjamin Moore everyone has their own style and flavor for things and luckily Benjamin Moore's got over 3,500 premium colors that make it easier to express yourself maybe brown when gay is a great match for your room where 1800s austerity is key or perfectly pesto green works wonderfully
你正在谈论的事情，但我只是想带你出去，只是为了满足我自己的痒，所以没错，抑郁症影响你的家庭有多久了？而且你喜欢炸薯球，我只是想得到那个，现在来自我们的赞助商的一句话，Smartless得到了本杰明·摩尔的支持，每个人都有自己的风格和品味，幸运的是，本杰明·摩尔有超过3500种优质颜色，让你更容易表达自己，也许“盖伊的棕色”非常适合你的房间，那里1800年代的朴素是关键，或者“完美香蒜绿”非常有效。
with your office that is approximately 92% plants or maybe comes down to how your life is going your long-term mood and outlook Benchman Moore makes it easy to switch things around to match up with your life so it should be noted that Robin Dre have just done a lot of work painting at their house I know they've done their deck and they've done their front gate turns out their contractor exclusively uses Benjamin Moore this is this is a guy who's a pro that's what he does and this is the paint that he decides to use I have seen firsthand Rob's deck and I gotta say and I don't
和你的办公室，大约92%是植物，或者也许归结为你的生活进展如何，你的长期情绪和前景，本杰明·摩尔让你很容易改变事情来匹配你的生活，所以应该指出，罗宾和德鲁刚刚在他们的房子里做了很多粉刷工作，我知道他们做了他们的甲板，他们做了他们的前门，事实证明他们的承包商专门使用本杰明·摩尔，这是一个专业人士，这就是他所做的，这是他决定使用的油漆，我亲眼见过罗布的甲板，我不得不说，而且我不。
want to I'm not I'm not I don't usually succumb to sort of hyperbole but it is off the effing charts it looks incredible but they're really really good you know they give they give great advice they really you know they're super helpful and you know the experience for I just speaking for Robin Andrew which I do a lot they they really loved it and but I won't let them say anything about it on here because it's just too tricky and we have to get lawyers involved and they have to sign releases anyway Benjamin Moore's paint is it's it's higher quality because you you've done well for yourself many things in your
想，我不是，我通常不会屈服于某种夸张，但它简直太棒了，看起来令人难以置信，但他们真的，真的很好，你知道，他们给，他们给很好的建议，他们真的，你知道，他们超级乐于助人，你知道，这种体验，我只是代表罗宾和安德鲁说话，我经常这样做，他们真的很喜欢它，但我不会让他们在这里说任何关于它的事情，因为它太棘手了，我们必须让律师参与进来，他们必须签署发布，总之，本杰明·摩尔的油漆，它，它质量更高，因为你，你做得很好，很多事情在你的。
life are of a higher quality you know your house your car personal belongings and of course the paint you use falls into this as well Benjamin Moore's paint is only sold at locally owned stores you can save 15% off on your next paint or sample purchase at Benjamin Moore.com using code smartless that's Benjamin Moore.com code smartless thanks to think for supporting this episode that's right think see recently I've been thinking about how much we kind of live our lives on autopilot the drive to work scrolling through social media while watching TV almost like we're just waiting for something to happen rather
生活中质量更高，你知道，你的房子，你的车，个人物品，当然你使用的油漆也属于这一类，本杰明·摩尔的油漆只在本地拥有的商店出售，你可以在BenjaminMoore.com上使用代码smartless节省15%的下一次油漆或样品购买，那是BenjaminMoore.com代码smartless，感谢Think支持这一集，没错，Think，最近我一直在想我们是如何在自动驾驶仪上过生活的，开车上班，在看电视时滚动社交媒体，几乎就像我们在等待某事发生，而不是。
than actively doing something we've all just turned into these robots who are living these monotonous lives we're always worried about a dystopian future don't worry it's the dystopian present that I'm nervous about we even eat without being mindful of why we're eating or what we're eating it's it's just time that we shake it up and that we change that and our friends that think want to help this spring they're challenging us to think strong and turn those thoughts into action to enrich our lives because think protein bars give you the strength you need to get the most out of life want to spend more time
积极地做某事，我们都变成了这些过着单调生活的机器人，我们总是担心反乌托邦的未来，别担心，让我紧张的是反乌托邦的现在，我们甚至在吃东西时没有意识到我们为什么吃，或者我们在吃什么，是时候让我们改变它，改变它了，我们的朋友Think想帮忙，这个春天，他们挑战我们去思考强大，并将这些想法转化为行动，以丰富我们的生活，因为Think蛋白棒给你在生活中获得最大收益所需的力量，想花更多时间。
doing something you actively enjoy don't just think about it make it a priority and do it think bars they're so great they're great on the go my buddy JB aka Jason Bateman he is a think bar junkie if that's a thing he's always got one of his golf bag he's always got one in his car because he just he gets sometimes he gets snacky and he needs something on the go to fuel his engine his tiny tiny little engine and to stay fueled up while you're out there going for it think strong and snack strong with great tasting high quality protein bars from think head to thinkproducts.com to learn more that's thinkproducts one word
做一些你积极享受的事情，不要只是想它，把它作为优先事项并去做，Think棒，它们太棒了，它们在旅途中很棒，我的哥们JB，也就是杰森·贝特曼，他是个Think棒迷，如果那是真的话，他总是把一个放在他的高尔夫球袋里，他总是把一个放在他的车里，因为他只是，他有时会感到饿，他需要一些在旅途中的东西来给他的引擎加油，他微小的，微小的引擎，并在你出去争取它时保持燃料充足，用来自Think的美味、高质量蛋白棒思考强大，零食强大，前往thinkproducts.com了解更多，那是thinkproducts一个词。
com hey smartlist listener we get support from Helix and thank our lucky stars that we do because since I've been sleeping on a Helix mattress which is going on a couple years now my sleep has made a dramatic improvement for reals I sleep longer more comfortably I wake up feeling more refreshed than ever because of sleeping on a Helix mattress this last couple years I got the Helix Midnight Lux mattress and I think Jason actually got the same one and Sean got the Helix Dusk Lux mattress and all three of us you know this when we first started doing this partnership and ads with with Helix we got these mattresses
com，嘿，Smartless听众，我们得到了Helix的支持，并感谢我们的幸运星，因为自从我睡在Helix床垫上，这已经快两年了，我的睡眠有了巨大的改善，真的，我睡得更久，更舒服，我醒来时感觉比以往任何时候都更清爽，因为睡在Helix床垫上，这最后几年，我买了Helix Midnight Lux床垫，我想杰森实际上买了同一个，肖恩买了Helix Dusk Lux床垫，我们三个人，你知道这个，当我们第一次开始这种合作和广告时，我们买了这些床垫。
and we're like oh you know making a mattress which is a big deal and it just went so well and we ended up ordering more and now all the mattresses in our house are Helix because they're just that comfortable here's here's what's the most important thing Helix their lineup includes 14 unique mattresses including a collection of luxury models and a mattress for big and tall sleepers and even a mattress made just for kids of which I have a few there are models with memory foam layers to provide optimal pressure relief if you sleep on your side or models with a more responsive foam to cradle your body
我们就像，哦，你知道，制造一个床垫，这是一个大问题，它进行得非常好，我们最终订购了更多，现在我们家里的所有床垫都是Helix，因为它们就是那么舒服，这是，这是最重要的事情，Helix，他们的阵容包括14种独特的床垫，包括一系列豪华型号，以及为高大睡眠者准备的床垫，甚至还有专门为孩子制作的床垫，我有几个，有带记忆泡沫层的型号，如果你侧睡，可以提供最佳的压力缓解，或者有更灵敏泡沫的型号来支撑你的身体。
for essential support in stomach and back sleeping positions Helix has been awarded the number one mattress picked by GQ and Wired Magazine and it's even recommended by multiple leading chiropractors and doctors of sleep medicine as a go-to solution for improving your sleep that's right people who are in the biz of sleep have given Helix over five Z's that's in the sleep biz that's their version of stars anyway it's a big deal Helix is offering up to 20% off all mattress orders and two free pillows for a listener go to helixsleep.com slash smartless this is their best offer yet and it won't last
为胃部和背部睡眠姿势提供必要的支撑，Helix被GQ和Wired杂志评为第一床垫选择，甚至被多位领先的脊椎按摩师和睡眠医学医生推荐为改善睡眠的首选解决方案，没错，从事睡眠行业的人给了Helix超过五个Z，那是在睡眠行业，那是他们的星星版本，总之，这是一个大问题，Helix为所有床垫订单提供高达20%的折扣和两个免费枕头，给听众，前往helixsleep.com/smartless，这是他们最好的优惠，而且它不会持续。
long that's helixsleep.com slash smartless with Helix better sleep starts now sorry I have night terrors and now back to the show wait so so you're you're editing we're editing and we just did reshoots last week we did three days of reshoots so I'm in this weird place of like did these reshoots and now I'm back in the edit bay plugging in what we reshot and the anxiety of like oh please tell me this works you know yeah and seeing how it plays out and going but then it's also that I'm also at that phase where really smart friends and people who have worked on the show or people I know writers or former editors
很久，那是helixsleep.com/smartless，有了Helix，更好的睡眠现在开始，抱歉，我有夜惊，现在回到节目，等等，所以，所以你在剪辑，我们正在剪辑，我们上周刚刚做了重拍，我们做了三天的重拍，所以我处于这种奇怪的状态，比如做了这些重拍，现在我回到了剪辑室，插入我们重拍的内容，那种焦虑，比如，哦，请告诉我这有效，你知道，是的，看着它如何发展，去，但这也是，我也处于那个阶段，真正聪明的，在节目中工作过的人，或者我认识的人，编剧或前剪辑师。
I will send them the episodes to be like how's it feeling haven't been sent anything you know I well you know I just I don't think so didn't you take now I feel like it hasn't been on for a while didn't you take a break was there a break or a COVID thing or something yeah well we had to for season between seasons two and three yeah yeah and then I shot I've been waiting no I've been I did three and four pretty much back to back huh yeah because of dr. Fauci dr. Fauci yeah because of Fauci because he wanted to do I keep going what's the end game what did he want to do he wanted to take over the planet what do you think
我会把剧集发给他们，比如感觉如何，还没发过任何东西，你知道，我，好吧，你知道，我只是，我不这么认为，你没拿，现在我觉得它已经有一段时间没播了，你没休息吗？有休息吗？或者新冠什么的，是的，好吧，我们在第二季和第三季之间不得不，是的，是的，然后我拍了，我一直在等，不，我一直在，我几乎背靠背做了三和四，哈，是的，因为福奇博士，福奇博士，是的，因为福奇，因为他想做，我一直在问，终局是什么？他想做什么？他想接管地球，你认为。
the Emmys what I say you you too Jason and Will were the two people the Emmys that pointed at my face and went mouth why are you wearing a mask I remember you wearing a mask I remember yeah Jason you were going why like malving are you sick stay away from me and I was the reason was because I was shooting and it was a thing of like if you get covered we shut down for two weeks lose all our locations people got to go home we lose crew yeah so I walked in and I was like there's literally no one with a mask here you were the only one I saw Bob Odenkirk and he's like do you have COVID Bob Bob Odenkirk and Bill so we were doing
艾美奖，我说，你，杰森和威尔，你们两个是艾美奖上指着我的脸说，嘴，你为什么戴口罩的人，我记得你戴着口罩，我记得，是的，杰森，你当时在问，为什么，像马尔文，你生病了吗？离我远点，我是原因是因为我正在拍摄，这就像，如果你得了新冠，我们关闭两周，失去我们所有的地点，人们必须回家，我们失去剧组，是的，所以我走进去，我当时想，这里真的没有人戴口罩，你是唯一一个我看到的，鲍勃·奥登科克，他说，你有新冠吗？鲍勃，鲍勃·奥登科克和比尔，所以我们当时在做。
brother Solomon and oh my god I was on a yeah and I know what you're gonna say Bill's on a recumbent bicycle okay yeah and so so we got the scene it's me and and and and wig and he kept having this thing and and but Bob was so obsessed with Bill and he goes oh oh oh my god buddy oh look at Bill on the recumbent and he says look up in the sky and Kristen wig is giving she's giving a performance where she has to cry you got to cry you remember this yes she has to cry and give this emotional speech and the joke is that while she's doing this the brother Solomon are watching me as this weird guy in a recumbent bike well
《所罗门兄弟》，哦，天哪，我在一个，是的，我知道你要说什么，比尔在骑斜躺自行车，好吧，所以，所以我们得到了那个场景，是我和，和，和威格，他一直有这个东西，而且，但鲍勃对比尔太着迷了，他说，哦，哦，哦，天哪，伙计，哦，看比尔在斜躺车上，他说，看天空，克里斯汀·威格正在表演，她必须哭，你必须哭，你记得这个吗？是的，她必须哭，并发表这个感人的演讲，笑话是，当她这样做时，所罗门兄弟正在看着我这个在斜躺自行车上的怪人，好吧。
he he was Bob was being one of the broson because Kristen was giving this amazing performance and he was like cut okay Bill what you got to do and she and our net was like hey Bob can we please acknowledge what she was doing this amazing work and he was like oh my god where did they find this thing did they invent this bike this isn't real is it oh my god it was so crazy it was so crazy it was like he's drawing on all this past pain pain and Bob Bob obsessed with Bill on the fucking bike and I just I really have respected our net for being like hey can we just acknowledge and then you're going to prison is another
他，他当时是鲍勃，因为克里斯汀正在进行精彩的表演，他就像，切，好吧，比尔，你必须做什么，她和我们的网就像，嘿，鲍勃，我们能承认她在做什么吗？这了不起的工作，他就像，哦，天哪，他们在哪里找到这个东西的？他们发明了这个自行车吗？这不是真的，是吗？哦，天哪，它太疯狂了，它太疯狂了，就像他在利用所有过去的痛苦，痛苦，而鲍勃，鲍勃沉迷于比尔在那个该死的自行车上，我只是，我真的很尊重我们的网，因为他就像，嘿，我们能承认吗？然后你要去监狱是另一个。
Odenkirk film that was incredible that was a great work yeah yeah it was a good but my very first audition for a movie was I auditioned for some part in that movie no way and Bob I remember reading with him and he took my sides away and he goes don't worry about these just talk to me oh really I was so scared I was so anxious I was so anxious because I was like he's a legend and the mr. show and everything and I was I was so terrified and I never auditioned before and I did the like by rote and a mirror like you know I did everything you know and what's the most money what's the most money you've ever spent in one trip to
奥登科克电影，那太不可思议了，那是一部伟大的作品，是的，是的，那是一部好的，但我第一次电影试镜是，我试镜了那部电影里的某个角色，不可能，鲍勃，我记得和他一起读，他拿走了我的台词，他说，别担心这些，只是跟我说话，哦，真的，我太害怕了，我太焦虑了，我太焦虑了，因为我当时想，他是传奇，还有《秀场先生》和一切，我，我太害怕了，我从没试镜过，我做了那种死记硬背和镜子，像，你知道，我做了所有事情，你知道，什么是你一次旅行中花的最多的钱。
Trader Joe's sorry about this bill on that while we're on food I want to I want to hear about your peanut allergy when was the last time you had a real I want to know when you had a real blow-up with peanuts how did Marty Short said you know Bill usually people when they talk about their allergies it's so boring but when you talk about it but what I do have a not allergy I do have a very bad how do you know what happened my mouth gets it just happened to me it just happened to me about a month ago I was entered I was doing it I was moderating Q&A with somebody and we went and ate beforehand and I ate lasagna I'm at you know a
乔氏超市，抱歉，比尔，关于那个，当我们谈论食物时，我想，我想听听你的花生过敏，你上次真正有一次，我想知道你什么时候真正爆发了花生，马蒂·肖特说，你知道，比尔，通常人们谈论他们的过敏时，太无聊了，但当你谈论它时，但我确实有坚果过敏，我确实有非常严重的，你怎么知道发生了什么？我的嘴变得，它刚刚发生在我身上，它刚刚发生在我身上，大约一个月前，我正在进入，我正在做，我正在主持一个问答环节，和某人一起，我们事先去吃了，我吃了千层面，我在，你知道，一个。
little Dom's and I eat lasagna and then suddenly my mouth goes numb and my throat starts to go go up and I go in the bathroom and I see I'm getting a rash on the side of my face and I go and so I ran in and there people are still talking and being going I go to the bathroom I ran down to there's like an Albertsons there something run inside find Benadryl take it in the aisle took like three of them and then went back and I just I just I had no EpiPen so I just did some Benadryl texted my doctor they were like okay you should be fine okay we're gonna put in a prescription here whatever and we were just figuring
小多姆餐厅，我吃了千层面，然后突然我的嘴麻木了，我的喉咙开始向上，我去洗手间，我看到我的脸侧面起了皮疹，我去，所以我跑进去，人们还在说话，还在，我去了洗手间，我跑下去，那里有个艾伯森超市，或者什么的，跑进去，找到苯海拉明，在过道里吃了，吃了大概三个，然后回去，我只是，我只是，我没有肾上腺素笔，所以我只是吃了一些苯海拉明，给我的医生发短信，他们就像，好吧，你应该没问题，好吧，我们要在这里开个处方，什么的，我们只是在弄清楚。
it out and I end up still doing the what would nuts be doing in lasagna it was vegan it was vegan vegan cheese it was cash I'm out okay it's not unusual in Los Feliz for actors just to be taking drugs in the aisles available that is true I was there was a bunch of other people and they're like you too man now so I don't remember when we were at the Dodger game and I and I eat tons and tons of peanuts I don't remember you getting nervous that I was near you with peanuts yeah you're not one of those no no it's not like the dust or something I have to like ingest it yeah yeah it's all right it's no fun no no
它，我最终还是做了，千层面里会有什么坚果？它是纯素的，它是纯素的，纯素奶酪，它是腰果，我出局了，好吧，在洛斯费利兹，演员在过道里吃药并不罕见，那是真的，我当时在那里，还有一群其他人，他们就像，你也一样，伙计，现在，我不记得我们在道奇队比赛时，我吃了成吨成吨的花生，我不记得你因为我在你附近有花生而感到紧张，是的，你不是那种人，不，不，不像灰尘什么的，我必须像摄入它，是的，是的，没关系，没乐趣，不，不。
by the way by the way Sean just very discreetly under his thing wrote down you just give me a lasagna he's just wrote it that's just gonna have for like like lasagna Garfield oh no I'm free you know what you know what Sean said to me by the way the other day this is totally true Jason I haven't told you this yet either Sean the other day just goes you know what I had for breakfast this morning I had a pot roast for breakfast and they go what just out of the blue what yes with mashed potatoes and then I had ice cream nine in the morning what are you being executed you being executed I mean we were at a meeting the other day
顺便说一句，顺便说一句，肖恩刚才非常谨慎地在他的东西下面写下，你刚才给了我一个千层面，他只是写了，那只是会像，像千层面，加菲猫，哦，不，我自由了，你知道吗，你知道肖恩那天对我说了什么，顺便说一句，这是完全真实的，杰森，我还没告诉你这个，肖恩那天只是说，你知道我今天早上早餐吃了什么吗？我早餐吃了炖牛肉，他们去，什么，只是突然，什么，是的，配土豆泥，然后我吃了冰淇淋，早上九点，你要被处决了吗？你要被处决了吗？我是说，我们那天在开会。
we were to meet in the other day and they made us a cake this is a cake that had our smartless pictures and names and stuff that was on the frosting on top just like is a gift like a sort of ceremonial like yeah it was kind of fun little thing and and Sean left the meeting with the cake full cake no hang on a second hang on a second walking out before the meeting started Sean cut into the cake and started eating it at the table his own table 30 people they made a cake for us and a business meeting he was like well it would be rude not to have a piece so he starts eating it and then he took it with him in his
我们在那天开会，他们给我们做了一个蛋糕，这是一个有我们Smartless照片和名字什么的蛋糕，在上面的糖霜上，就像是一个礼物，一种仪式性的，像，是的，这是一种有趣的小东西，而且，肖恩带着蛋糕离开了会议，整个蛋糕，不，等一下，等一下，在会议开始前走出来，肖恩切开了蛋糕，开始在桌子上吃，他自己的桌子，30个人，他们为我们做了一个蛋糕，在商务会议上，他就像，好吧，不吃一块会很粗鲁，所以他开始吃它，然后他把它带走了，在他的。
car but he left he came down out of CA with this cake with his own fucking face on it but he lives he lives with his husband and a dog that's you said you'd have half of it done by the end of the week that's got his god diabetes he's not eating the cake so it's all Sean so Bill Bill what's your current temperature no no Sean serious question how much of the cake is left this is not that night he had more and that morning the next morning right Sean there's five days later how much I kind of wanted it done like if you're an adult and you have all the cake you can eat why wouldn't you eat it right are you self-aware when
车里，但他离开了，他带着这个蛋糕从CA下来，上面有他自己该死的脸，但他住，他和他的丈夫和一只狗住在一起，你说你会在周末结束前吃掉它的一半，那家伙有糖尿病，他不吃蛋糕，所以全是肖恩的，所以比尔，比尔，你现在的温度是多少？不，不，肖恩，严肃的问题，蛋糕还剩多少？这不是那天，他吃了更多，那天早上，第二天早上，对吧，肖恩，这是五天后，多少，我有点想吃完它，就像如果你是一个成年人，你有所有你可以吃的蛋糕，你为什么不吃它，对吧，你有自我意识吗？
that's happening Sean are you like you have guilt you have shame no shame no you know what I think it is like I just can't stop I think we grew up with nothing anytime anytime I'm like oh my god free cake free cake tell me how much of the cake is left it's gone is it really yes well that was a week that was you shit pig almost a week ago shit pig yeah you just know I get that I don't know I get it I get it I do get it where it's like we're just gonna leave this here come on I know there is a lot of that and there's a lot of waste and what we do um final question how high can you jump if you really want to jump high
当这种情况发生时，肖恩，你有内疚吗？你有羞耻吗？没有羞耻，你知道我认为它是什么，就像我只是停不下来，我想我们成长时什么都没有，任何时候，我就像，哦，天哪，免费蛋糕，免费蛋糕，告诉我蛋糕还剩多少，它没了，真的吗？是的，好吧，那是一个星期，那是你，屎猪，几乎是一个星期前，屎猪，是的，你只是知道，我明白了，我不知道，我明白了，我确实明白了，就像我们只是要把它留在这里，来吧，我知道有很多那种情况，而且有很多浪费，我们所做的，嗯，最后一个问题，如果你真的想跳得很高，你能跳多高？
how high by the way here's the other thing Bill you work with our group with our old dear friend on Barry Henry Winkler oh yeah I love him I love him Henry's so sweet he's the greatest the sweetest yeah he's always like like you doubt his sincerity he's so damn nice does he still leave his ringer on on his phone while you're rolling does he do that no no he doesn't we had we have a blooper wheel that's dedicated from the first couple seasons of domestic to Henry's phone going off in the middle of a scene it by the way usually during his own dialogue so he'd be doing yeah he'd be doing a courtroom scene going
多高，顺便说一句，这是另一件事，比尔，你在《巴瑞》上和我们的团队，和我们的老朋友亨利·温克勒一起工作，哦，是的，我爱他，我爱他，亨利太甜了，他是最伟大的，最甜的，是的，他总是像，你怀疑他的真诚，他太该死的好人了，他还在滚动时让他的手机铃声响着吗？他那样做吗？不，不，他没有，我们有一个专门的NG镜头，是从《国内》的前几季开始的，专门针对亨利在场景中间响起的手机，顺便说一句，通常是在他自己的对话期间，所以他会做，是的，他会做一场法庭戏，去。
what do we have to and then ring oh my god hang on a second oh it's Stacy hold on Jason we have a great blooper of Jason going go ahead and take that one just take it Henry he's so sweet Henry one time we were doing a thing and you know my character fought in Afghanistan and in three takes in a row he said Vietnam yeah really I have him on my phone and when Barry was fighting in Vietnam that's not right hold on and then every Friday it's like Henry that was a great take where you had to have a you know mental breakdown that was really good he's like you got me there I have this chocolate bunt cake from Jersey
我们有什么，然后铃声，天哪，等一下，哦，是Stacy，等一下Jason，我们有一个很棒的Jason的NG片段，去吧，拿那个，Henry，拿走吧，他太贴心了，Henry，有一次我们在拍戏，你知道我的角色在阿富汗打仗，他连续拍了三遍都说越南，真的，我手机里还有录音，当Barry在越南打仗时，那不对，等一下，然后每个星期五，就像Henry，那是一个很棒的镜头，你必须有一个，你知道，精神崩溃，那真的很好，他说你抓到我了，我有这个来自Jersey的巧克力磅蛋糕
City in the trunk of my car he is absolutely the greatest amazing work and I think he gets very anxious about his dramatic work but he's such a good dramatic actor and he really will go where he need you know he's not afraid or whatever but it is funny how much he he'll have that moment and then he you know turns it right on you know this season especially goes through a lot of stuff but when he do that and then yeah he'll offer you sweets such a talent you know he was one of the guys when we were first doing a rest of development and I was living in New York but coming out here to do it and I'd be oftentimes you
在我车后备箱里的城市，他绝对是最棒的，工作令人惊叹，我觉得他在处理戏剧性工作时会非常焦虑，但他是一个非常好的戏剧演员，他真的会去他需要去的地方，你知道，他不害怕什么的，但很有趣的是，他会有那一刻，然后他，你知道，立刻就转过来了，你知道，这一季尤其经历了很多事情，但当他这样做时，然后是的，他会给你提供甜点，真是个天才，你知道，当我们刚开始做《发展受阻》时，他是其中之一，我住在纽约，但来到这里拍摄，我经常会你
know I was friends with these guys a little bit but you know whatever I didn't have anywhere and he and his wife Stacy would invite me over on Saturday mornings and I would go over there and just you know have breakfast with him and with the family all the time he was so sweet I know they were so generous oh yeah we pretty much every month go and have breakfast like once you know like and it's and it's great and he is kind of like so how are you doing like outside of everything how's your life how's this how's this feeling like he's just I always walk away from those feeling you know better but I want to
知道，我和这些人有点朋友关系，但你知道，无论如何，我无处可去，他和他的妻子Stacy会在周六早上邀请我过去，我会过去，只是，你知道，和他们以及家人一起吃早餐，他一直都很贴心，我知道他们非常慷慨，哦是的，我们几乎每个月都会去吃早餐，你知道，就像，这很棒，他会问你，你怎么样，在这一切之外，你的生活怎么样，这种感觉怎么样，就像他只是，我每次离开时都感觉，你知道，更好，但我想要
grow up in his house well you remember back then back then it was like when his son Max was still in high school yeah and and his best buddy was Jonah Hill and those guys were still in fucking high school when I was there like this is like 2003 like the fall of 2003 all was it yeah yeah those guys were still in high school him and Jonah and they were like oh man we love a rest of development and they were they were like fucking 17 you know or if that so weird anyway yeah 2003 Sean wanted to know have you ever had to put snow tires on he just he texted that in he said just please ask him I'm so glad you got
在他家里长大，好吧，你还记得那时候，那时候就像他的儿子Max还在上高中，是的，他最好的哥们是Jonah Hill，当我在那里时，那些家伙还在上高中，这就像2003年，2003年秋天，是吗，是的，那些家伙还在上高中，他和Jonah，他们就像，哦天哪，我们喜欢《发展受阻》，他们当时才17岁，你知道，如果真是那样的话，太奇怪了，不管怎样，是的，2003年，Sean想知道你有没有装过雪地轮胎，他发短信问的，他说请一定要问他，我很高兴你及时
it in time that's a great question can you build because I'm such a massive hammer I'm such a massive fan can you do just I know you're not a singing monkey here we go can you do Vincent price just a little bit because it's so fucking funny oh thank I'm trying well the thing I remember the John Mulaney's first night of riding at SNL he the Seth Meyers said oh we maybe we should bring the new guy in and help him Vincent price and we were riding a thing and it was Fred would play Liberace and I'm Vincent price and we're arguing yeah and and we're arguing is as you do right still with you yeah yeah so he's
得到了，那是个好问题，你能模仿吗，因为我是个超级粉丝，我是个超级粉丝，你能模仿一下Vincent Price吗，就一点点，因为那太搞笑了，哦谢谢，我在努力，好吧，我记得John Mulaney在SNL写剧本的第一晚，Seth Meyers说，哦，也许我们应该带新人进来帮他，Vincent Price，我们当时在写一个东西，Fred会扮演Liberace，我是Vincent Price，我们在争论，是的，我们在争论，就像你做的那样，对吧，还在你身边，是的，是的，所以他
well with you this is this by the way this is this is in 2008 when people are still really excited with Vincent price and Liberace and as Lauren said I like to sketch but why now but Liberace and they're talking and we're like oh what's that thing Vincent price could say to Liberace after he burns him or something and and and John Mulaney came up the line save your sassia sides for your windowless bars Fred would yeah Liberace was always him talking about like a prince who had given him a jewel or something yeah and anyway Jack Nicholson John Malkovich
还在你身边，顺便说一下，这是在2008年，当时人们仍然对Vincent Price和Liberace感到非常兴奋，正如Lauren所说，我喜欢小品，但为什么是现在，但Liberace，他们在谈话，我们就像，哦，Vincent Price在羞辱他之后能对Liberace说什么，或者类似的话，然后John Mulaney想出了那句台词，把你的俏皮话留给你的无窗酒吧，Fred会，是的，Liberace总是谈论一个送给他珠宝的王子什么的，是的，不管怎样，Jack Nicholson，John Malkovich
all of them I fucking love all of them oh thank you very much yeah but the and then yeah that line always we were just like whoa but like what about that what it like are there ever gonna be another vehicle where we can see you do your impressions or is it just there's a chapter clothes like Camel or something they'll be like like what I want to Camel like not too long ago and you have me do all the Dateline people right because I watched Dateline a lot like all the Dateline people so I did them and but yeah usually it's like you're at a party or something and you know you know who loves like it comments yeah yeah calling
所有这些人，我他妈的爱死他们了，哦非常感谢，是的，但是，然后是的，那句台词总是，我们当时就像，哇，但是，关于那个，有没有其他的载体可以看到你做模仿，还是说这只是一个章节的结束，像Camel什么的，他们会像，像我想要Camel，不久前，你让我模仿所有的Dateline人物，对吧，因为我经常看Dateline，就像所有的Dateline人物，所以我模仿了他们，但是是的，通常就像你在派对上，你知道，你知道谁喜欢，像评论，是的，是的，称呼
it you know loves impressions is Larry David yeah yeah he loves Shawn just did some work with him his mind when you do an impression of anybody can you do Larry David wait who would you who would you who would you who would you trust to do you oh man everybody does I mean yeah I mean Fred does a really good meme which is does he really his impression of me everybody's impression of me is like hey then what's going on and fell and then his impression means I've always just discovered a super famous band you know I started listening to his Bruce Springsteen you always walk into my office and you're like you know he's
它，你知道，喜欢模仿的是Larry David，是的，是的，他喜欢，Shawn刚和他一起工作过，当你模仿任何人的时候，他的大脑，你能模仿Larry David吗，等等，谁会，谁会，谁会，谁会，你信任谁来模仿你，哦天哪，每个人都会，我是说，是的，我是说Fred模仿得很好，是一个很棒的模因，他是真的吗，他模仿我，每个人模仿我都是，嘿，怎么了，然后，他的模仿意味着我总是刚刚发现一个超级著名的乐队，你知道，我开始听他的Bruce Springsteen，你总是走进我的办公室，然后你就像，你知道他是
an almond brother pretty good do really quick do Jack Nicholson watching Dateline I don't know if I do Jack Nicholson oh we're doing to a Jack Nicholson but you know oh you know who Larry David likes is a Burt Lancaster Burt Lancaster when he there's this this guy told me a story this made Larry David laugh really hard was a guy worked for Burt Lancaster and he brought him some chowder for lunch and he said that Burt Lancaster looked in the bag and looked up at him and he went oyster crackers you forgot the oyster crackers you know that's it's always fun I do it do it on set and it gets old fast no
一个Almond Brother，很不错，快点，模仿一下Jack Nicholson看Dateline，我不知道我能不能模仿Jack Nicholson，哦，我们在模仿Jack Nicholson，但你知道，哦，你知道Larry David喜欢谁吗，是Burt Lancaster，Burt Lancaster，当他，有个家伙告诉我一个故事，这让Larry David笑得很厉害，是一个为Burt Lancaster工作的人，他给他带了一些杂烩汤作为午餐，他说Burt Lancaster看了看袋子，抬头看着他，然后他说，牡蛎饼干，你忘了牡蛎饼干，你知道，这总是很有趣，我在片场做，很快就过时了，不
actually nothing I've never had setups in between shots feel shorter than when I worked with you on on Paul you're yeah it's just so fun to hang out yeah we were do you remember when they blew up the house and Paul yeah yeah and they said yeah you guys are gonna stand right here okay and we went okay and then me and you were looking at each other you know what I want to go stand with a special effects right the guy standing behind a barricade where we were standing was a giant car or something land like massive debris landed where we were we were like this isn't fun no yeah that was my god wait a second I love that
实际上没有，我从来没有觉得镜头之间的设置比我和你在《保罗》合作时更短，是的，和你在一起玩太有趣了，是的，我们，你还记得他们炸掉房子的时候吗，在《保罗》里，是的，是的，他们说，是的，你们俩就站在这里，好吗，我们说好的，然后我和你看着对方，你知道吗，我想去和特效人员站在一起，站在路障后面的家伙，我们站的地方，是一个巨大的汽车什么的，像巨大的碎片落在了我们站的地方，我们当时就像，这不好玩，不，是的，天哪，等一下，我喜欢这个
you're telling us because Jason doesn't remember and he by the way he he never would have told us that story never never comes up now he also were you there when the guys made us drink jalapeno stuff I like the like the I think you're aren't you with us I might have been there's me and Simon Pag and everybody and they're like hey you guys are Hollywood people you know like we were in New Mexico and they were like oh these loud Hollywood people and they were like hey here drink a shot of this and it wasn't it was pure jalapeno juice it's not alcoholic because I was like oh I don't drink and they're like
你告诉我们，因为Jason不记得了，顺便说一下，他永远不会告诉我们那个故事，从来没提过，还有，当那些家伙让我们喝墨西哥辣椒汁时，你在场吗，我喜欢，我想你，你不是和我们在一起吗，我可能在，有我和Simon Pegg还有其他人，他们就像，嘿，你们这些好莱坞的人，你知道，就像我们在新墨西哥州，他们就像，哦，这些吵闹的好莱坞人，他们就像，嘿，喝了这个，这不是酒精，因为我当时说，哦，我不喝酒，他们就像
that's it was jalapeno juice and we had to run and get milk and stuff it was a way of like get the fuck out of here starting to sound familiar that was like that was like that was fun let me tell you what was fun Bill was this chat we could do two full episodes we haven't gotten into any of your of your incredible voiceover work and all these animated films too I mean it's it's on and on and on you're an incredible talent multi-dimensional or whatever it is you're you're that and well done good to see you dude I'm calling you for Dodger game soon yeah please all right have a good day bud you
那是墨西哥辣椒汁，我们不得不跑去拿牛奶什么的，这是一种让你滚蛋的方式，开始听起来很熟悉了，那就像，那就像，那很有趣，让我告诉你什么很有趣，Bill，这次聊天，我们可以做两集完整的节目，我们还没有深入探讨你令人难以置信的配音工作和所有这些动画电影，我的意思是，它没完没了，你是一个令人难以置信的天才，多维的，或者不管它是什么，你是那样的，做得好，很高兴见到你，伙计，我很快会给你打电话看道奇队的比赛，是的，请，好的，祝你今天愉快，伙计，你
but thank you bye bye bye bye all right I don't think there's anything that guy can't do yeah that was funny stuff man it was dramatic he acts writes directs produces high quality person friends I'm just kind of blown away that he went on SNL and then just had all those characters like what are the odds of yeah let's take a chance on Bill Hader and then you got all this stuff inside of yeah it's so funny he's always got it's funny that he said that that he does that appropriation thing because it is you see that in a nervous thing yeah where he's just like oh and he starts doing the voice while he's I do that all the
但是谢谢，再见，再见，再见，好的，我不认为有什么是那个家伙做不到的，是的，那很有趣，伙计，这很戏剧性，他表演、写作、导演、制作，高质量的人，朋友，我只是有点震惊，他去了SNL，然后就有了所有那些角色，就像，这几率是多少，是的，让我们给Bill Hader一个机会，然后你就在里面得到了所有这些东西，是的，太搞笑了，他总是，很有趣的是他说那个，他做了那种挪用，因为确实，你在紧张的事情中看到了这一点，是的，他只是，哦，他开始在做的时候发出声音，我一直都在做那个
time with I'll take people's laughter I'll start laughing like them yeah for some weird reason and that'll be like my new laugh for a few weeks I think it's like a common human thing I do find that I just yammer and yammer and yammer when I'm socially uncomfortable I will I'll do the opposite of what you think you would do which is just shrivel and go into a corner and be quiet I should just start talking I just start speaking whatever I'm thinking of in my mind yeah I mean I see I notice you at parties and you kind of do on this I see you talk into somebody when you're engaging with like another person and you're just
时间，我会模仿人们的笑声，我会开始像他们一样笑，是的，出于某种奇怪的原因，那会成为我几周内的新笑声，我认为这是一种常见的人类行为，我确实发现，当我在社交上感到不舒服时，我只是喋喋不休，喋喋不休，喋喋不休，我会做你认为你会做的相反的事情，那就是萎缩，躲进角落里，保持安静，我应该只是开始说话，我只是开始说我脑子里想到的任何事情，是的，我的意思是，我注意到你在派对上，你有点这样做，我看到你和某人说话，当你和另一个人互动时，你只是
talking at them and you're like asking them and you're just fucking and they're thinking like oh at first they're like I get such a trace of Bateman and then they want to fucking kill themselves do you blah blah blah and you're like you're going but the question it's like the show you're asking questions and it's on and on I know and and I just often they have a look of what I would describe only is disgust yeah my family kicked me out of the house a couple days ago but you know what Jay you with all that work on your mouth that you've had you're talking so beautifully and I'm glad you finally got
对着他们说话，你就像在问他们，你只是他妈的，他们心想，哦，起初他们就像，我从Bateman那里得到了这样的痕迹，然后他们想他妈的自杀，你吧啦吧啦，你就像，你在继续，但问题是，就像节目一样，你在问问题，没完没了，我知道，而且他们经常有一种我只能描述为厌恶的表情，是的，我的家人几天前把我赶出了家门，但你知道吗，Jay，你嘴上做的所有那些工作，你说话说得真好，我很高兴你终于得到了
that to fix which one was it called I think it was a bye then repeat it again and say hi look at what will harmonizing I didn't love it it was too early well my god you're kidding Smart List Smart List is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by Rob Armjirv Bennett Barbaco and Michael Grant Terry smart loss our next episode will be out in a week wherever you listen to podcasts or you can listen to it right now early on Amazon music or early and add free by subscribing to Wondery Plus in Apple podcasts or the Wondery app There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
那个来修复，那是哪一个，我想是再见，然后重复一遍，说嗨，看看什么会和谐，我不喜欢它，太早了，天哪，你在开玩笑，Smart List，Smart List是100%有机的，由Rob Armjirv Bennett Barbaco和Michael Grant Terry手工制作，Smart List，我们的下一集将在下周播出，无论你在哪里听播客，或者你现在就可以在Amazon Music上提前收听，或者通过订阅Apple Podcasts或Wondery应用程序中的Wondery Plus提前收听且无广告，这一集还没有评论，点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。